Wenn ungefähr 400.000 Jahre alte elektronische Klänge aus dem Fritzradio rauskommen und irgendwelche komischen Zahlen gezählt werden, dann ist unweigerlich letzter Mittwoch im Monat. Das heißt Chaosradio. Hallo und herzlich willkommen liebe Freunde an den neuartigen Rundfunk-Empfangsgeräten. Chaosradio heißt der Chaos Computer Club, kommt hier einmal im Monat ins Studio, übernimmt es. Ich darf noch so ein bisschen Knöpfchen drücken. Und ansonsten erzählen sie lustige Sachen aus der Welt der Bits und Bites, aus der Multimedia-Welt, wie man in den 80er Jahren gesagt hätte. Heute zu Gast Thorsten Schröder. Hallo, guten Tag und Konstanze Kurz. Konstanze Kurz war schon öfter hier, habt ihr vielleicht auch ab und zu mal im Fernsehen gesehen, ist relativ präsent für den CCC. Also immer da zu finden, wo es etwas öffentlich zu sehen gibt, kann man so sagen. Und Thorsten Schröder, den Namen habt ihr aber auch gehört, wenn ihr in der letzten Zeit euch mit den Themen beschäftigt habt, die da so elektronisch herumschwirren. Der Name taucht auf zusammen mit dem anderen, nämlich Max Moser war es, wenn ich richtig gemerkt habe. Die beiden haben nämlich zwei Dinge untersucht. Und das eine davon soll in Zukunft unser elektronisches Leben viel einfacher machen. Nämlich der EPA. Nein, das heißt jetzt NPA, also der elektronische Personalausweis. Das heißt, dieses Ding, was wir ab November alle kriegen sollen, wo unsere biometrischen Daten genau wie im Reisepass abgespeichert werden und mit dem wir uns in Zukunft im Internet ausweisen können. Und das wird alles total toll. In der Schweiz gibt es etwas, was nicht genau dasselbe ist, aber was thematisch irgendwie zusammenpasst, wie das zusammenpasst. Das kleine Malte auch noch ganz so heißt das SuisseID. Und Thorsten hat zusammen mit Max das Ding mal ausführlich unter die Lupe genommen. Und dabei sind ein paar interessante Sachen rausgekommen, die eigentlich was bedeuten. Also was heißt das für uns, was ihr da rausgefunden habt?
Naja, ich muss dazu sagen, wir haben nichts rausgefunden, was jetzt irgendwie bahnbrechend oder neu wäre.
Okay, Sendung vorbei, wir hören Musik. Tschüss.
Genau, tschüss. Nein, im Endeffekt haben wir uns jetzt einfach mal die Mühe gemacht, aufgrund einer aktuellen Anfrage die einzelnen Kritikpunkte, die an diesem System existieren, einfach mal auf den Punkt zu bringen. Das haben wir getan in Form eines Vortrages und haben in diesem Zuge versucht diese Angriffspunkte, die wir da gefunden haben, auch auf den deutschen EPA zu übertragen und hatten damit Erfolg. Das liegt einfach daran, dass wir uns das aus einem sehr hohen, aus einem High-Level-Perspektive angesehen haben.
Aber Erfolg ist in diesem Fall eher so zu werten, wie das positive Ergebnis eines Krankheitstests. Ihr hättet lieber keinen Erfolg gehabt.
Ja, so kann man das natürlich sagen. Der Sinn von dieser SuisseID ist ja, dass man eben Dokumente signieren kann oder sich an irgendwelchen online Geschäften oder Banken authentifizieren kann.
Also heißt es statt Unterschrift?
Na ja, statt Username, Passwort oder PIN, einfach so ein elektronisches Token, also so ein USB-Token hat mit einer Smartcard drinne. Und ähnlich funktioniert ja dann der EPA am Endeffekt auch. Wir haben hier eine Smartcard mit einem Zertifikat und wollen uns damit dann authentifizieren. Man hört halt immer wieder, dass die Sicherheit dadurch deutlich und massiv erhöht werden soll. Und wir wollten im Endeffekt eigentlich nur zeigen, dass das nicht der Fall ist. Also wir haben... Okay, warte, halt.
Das ist nämlich genau der Punkt, zu sagen, damit beschäftigen wir uns die nächsten zwei Stunden. Und wir machen das im Chaosradio für gewöhnlicherweise so. Wir fangen ganz von vorne an. Das heißt, wenn ihr zwischendurch irgendwie reinschaltet, versteht ihr möglicherweise nichts mehr. Aber wenn ihr ab jetzt zuhört und bis zum Ende mitmacht, dann habt ihr einmal das ganze Thema bekommen. Und anfangen, wenn ihr zwischendurch was nicht versteht, gilt anrufen. Weil dann können wir euch die Frage möglicherweise beantworten. Jetzt anrufen! 0331 70 97 110 Das gilt auch nachher, wenn wir die Einführung hinter uns gebracht haben, für das Thema selber. Weil letztendlich sollt ihr das da draußen benutzen. Ihr sollt den elektronischen Personalausweis irgendwann kriegen. Und vielleicht sagt ihr, hey, das ist eine super Idee, ist mir egal. Ob es da Bedenken gibt. Ich will das trotzdem haben, weil es macht vieles einfacher. Oder vielleicht sagt ihr, das ist mir zu teuer, habe prinzipiell eine gute Idee. Oder ihr sagt, das ist eine schlimme Idee. Was kann man dagegen machen? Wie auch immer. Anrufen 0331 70 97 110 So, und jetzt fangen wir von vorne an. Elektronischer Personalausweis. Ich habe gerade schon ein bisschen aufgeteilt, was das können soll. Da hat Constanze schon mit der Stirn gerundet. Das stimmt gar nicht, was der da erzählt.
Nein, das war nur der Vergleich mit dem Reisepass. Es gibt ja bereits den biometrischen elektronischen Reisepass. Und da sind aber ein paar Unterschiede.
Also dann jetzt ganz langsam von vorne. Was kann der elektronische Personalausweis? Oder was soll er können?
Wenn man es jetzt mal rein von der logischen Funktionalität ansieht, hat er drei Funktionen. Das ist die sogenannte hochheitliche Funktion. Das bezieht sich insbesondere auf die biometrischen Daten, aber auch auf die normalen Ausweisdaten, die aufgedruckt sind, heute auf dem Ausweis und später ja auch auf dem Ausweis. Da wird nur etwa die Polizei oder Behörden, die ein Erlaubnis dazu haben, zugreifen können. Das ist der sogenannte hoheitliche Bereich. Der zweite Bereich ist eben die Identitätsfunktion, wird auch abgekürzt mit EID, wo man also nachweisen soll, im virtuellen Geschäftsverkehr, dass man derjenige ist, der man zu sein scheint. Und der dritte Bereich ist die sogenannte qualifizierte elektronische Signatur, wo man also eine Unterschrift leisten soll, die äquivalent im virtuellen Bereich ist, wie die Unterschrift, die man eben zum Beispiel persönlich leistet, wenn man irgendwo unterzeichnet. Und die Bereiche haben natürlich auch unterschiedliche Formen von Kritikpunkten, die sie nach sich ziehen. Bei der SuisseID ist es technisch ein bisschen anders, aber wir haben eben doch gewisse Parallelen gesehen. Die SuisseID ist tatsächlich keine viereckige Polycarbonatkarte, sondern die ist eine ganz kleine SD-Karte in einem USB-Stick. Und um sich eben gegenüber einem Anbieter zu identifizieren, schiebt man die in seinen USB-Slot. Aber weswegen wir die eigentlich gemeinsam betrachtet haben, ist natürlich, dass man gewisserweise ähnliche Funktionen, zumindest teilweise, damit durchführen kann. Und in der Schweiz ist halt diese SuisseID schon im Einsatz. Das heißt, wir hatten auch die Möglichkeit, dann die höheren tatsächlichen Funktionen anzugucken.
Da gibt es tatsächliche Anwendungen, die man sich dann auch anschauen kann, ob das tatsächlich so toll jetzt alles funktioniert.
Also ein Unterschied ist schon mal, die SuisseID ist kein staatliches Ausweisinstrument. Und ein anderer Unterschied ist, dass es da schon im Einsatz ist. Was habt ihr beim EPA getestet? Irgendwie eine Beta-Version oder was?
Na, wir haben geguckt, wie die Anwendungstests heute laufen. Also was so angeboten wird an Test-Applikationen. Wir haben natürlich diese sogenannte Ausweis-App, wie sie jetzt neuerdings heißt. Früher hieß sie Bürgerclient. Mal runtergeladen, installiert. Wir haben verschiedene Lesegeräte ausprobiert. Wir haben einfach geguckt, zum Beispiel, ob die High-Level-Angriffe, die bei der SuisseID gut funktionieren, für den deutschen Ausweis funktionieren und welche davon und wie. Wir waren teilweise, müssen wir mal ganz offen gestehen, selber ein bisschen überrascht, wie gut das funktioniert hat.
Und in manchen Fällen konnten wir das einfach nicht zeigen, weil viele große Teile einfach nicht funktioniert haben oder uns nicht zur Verfügung standen.
Also ihr habt aber sozusagen schon mit einer Testversion dieses Ausweises gearbeitet?
Prototypen, die sind ja heute auch vergeben worden. Es gab schon verschiedene Prototypen, aber wir hatten natürlich schon immer jeweils den aktuellen. Aber es gibt Bereiche, die konnten wir nicht testen, weil man zum Beispiel die qualifizierte elektronische Signatur noch gar nicht auch nicht im Testbereich mit dem neuen Ausweis durchführen kann.
Jetzt sagen, also ihr habt es irgendwie verglichen, aber die Übereinstimmungen sind jetzt eher konzeptueller Natur, konnte man sagen.
Das kann man so sagen, genau.
Also das ist nicht so, dass irgendwie SuisseID und elektronischer Personalausweis technisch gesehen dieselben Geräte sind, sondern ihr habt es deswegen zusammengepackt, weil es zwei Dinge sind, über die online Identität festgestellt werden kann.
Und vor allen Dingen, weil wir uns gar nicht die technische Implementierung, all dieser Systeme angeschaut haben. Das war gar nicht Sinn dieser Übung. Wir wollten uns wirklich dieses Konzeptionelle anschauen. Das heißt, wir haben uns nicht irgendwie geschaut, dass wir irgendeinen bestimmten Hersteller hernehmen, irgendeine bestimmte Software-Komponent oder irgendein Device und das zerpflücken und öffentlich präsentieren, sondern wir wollten eigentlich eher auf ein grundsätzliches Problem aufmerksam machen, das natürlich auch durch die ganzen Politiker und die wirtschaftlichen Unternehmen, die die hinter diesen ganzen Geräten und Produkten stecken, diese Augenwischerei, die da betrieben wird und unterstützt wird, dass man da die einfach mal angreift, aufgreift und das thematisiert in der Öffentlichkeit, denn alle Bürger sind davon betroffen, insbesondere in Deutschland, wo dieses Dokument eben einfach Pflicht wird für jeden Bürger.
Das stimmt nicht ganz. Also das ist zwar ein Gesetz, aber man muss in Deutschland keinen Personalausweis haben.
Ja, aber man kriegt halt keinen herkömmlichen Ausweis mehr. Wer jetzt einen Personalausweis haben möchte und jeder wird einen bekommen müssen, irgendwann früher oder später, der wird halt diesen elektronischen Personalausweis bekommen. Also man kann sich da im Endeffekt nicht gegenwehren. In der Schweiz gibt es gerüchteweise die Idee, dieses Verfahren, was dort derzeit im Einsatz ist, später im Jahr 2014 vielleicht auch in elektronische Ausweisdokumente zu integrieren. Das ist allerdings jetzt auch nur etwas, was ich in den vergangenen Tagen auch so aufgeschnappt habe.
Also im Prinzip möchte ich die Diskussion an dieser Stelle mal so zusammenfassen. Die Politik sagt, das ist voll sicher, und ihr sagt, das stimmt gar nicht.
Wir wollten vor allem auch mal zeigen, wie man es praktisch demonstrieren kann, dass es nicht der Fall ist. Denn behaupten kann man immer viel.
Aber das ist grob gesagt, dass es die Diskussion, die wir gerade haben.
Ja, aber es gibt auch ein gewisser Aufklärungsgedanke dahinter, weil wir uns da schon auch in der Rolle sehen, auf Sachen hinzuweisen, auf die offiziell nicht hingewiesen wurde. Das hängt auch ein bisschen damit zusammen, dass wir mittlerweile die Broschüren bekommen haben und die Webseiten, die ja dann angeboten werden von dem Bürger, werden natürlich auch mal mit der Hotline telefoniert. Wir haben uns einen Überblick darüber verschafft, wie eigentlich der Bürger aufgeklärt wird. Und da war uns diese ganze Lobhudelei und dieses Projekt schon suspekt.
Diese ganze Lobhudelei, das möchte ich dir sehr schnell nochmal erwähnen, hat natürlich auch zu einer Reaktion des Innenministers geführt. Der hat ja im Zuge dessen, dass das bekannt wurde, folgendes gesagt.
Irgendwelche Hacker mögen immer irgendwas hacken können, aber die Zuverlässigkeit und Sicherheit des neuen Personalausweises steht nicht in Frage.
Das ist ja das Internet, nicht das Internet, wenn es aus so einem großartigen Zitat nicht sofort etwas machen würde. Und was das Internet daraus gemacht hat, das hören wir uns jetzt an. Und danach geht es gleich los und wir werden den Personalausweis mal ein bisschen genau auseinandernehmen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Aber die Zuverlässigkeit und Sicherheit des Nordpersonalausweises steht nicht in Frage.
Sagen.
Ich bin der Beste der ganzen Welt. Ich bin der Beste der ganzen Welt. Ich bin der Beste der ganzen Welt.
Ich bin der Beste der ganzen Welt.
Ich bin der Beste der ganzen Welt. Ich bin der Beste der ganzen Welt.
Ich bin der Beste der ganzen Welt. Aber die Zuverlässigkeit und Sicherheit ist noch in Personalausweise, steht nicht in Frage.
Aber Sicherheit heißt das Ganze, von Sicherheitsstudios ist irgendwo im Netz aufgetaucht und beschäftigt sich mit der aktuellen Problematik der elektronischen Personalausweis. Und ich finde, an diesem Track ist genau wie an dieser Epa-Nummer noch einiges zu verbessern. Also das ist schon eine gute Idee, aber das geht noch besser, falls ihr also da draußen irgendwie den Remix in den Fingern habt. Gerne. Das Zitat ist ja da auch im Netz verfügbar. So, wir aber heute hier mit dem elektronischen Personalausweis, der wurde von zwei Leuten mehr oder weniger auseinandergenommen, nämlich Thorsten Schröder, der ist hier im Studio und Max Moser. Und das will ich jetzt mal ein bisschen genauer wissen. Das erste, was mir ausgefallen ist an dieser Meldung, die ihr dazu rausgebracht habt, ist, dass ihr gesagt habt, na ja, wir haben jetzt eigentlich nicht irgendwie doll schwierige Dinge gemacht, sondern wir haben mit Hausmitteln gekocht, möchte ich mal sagen. Also es wurde irgendwie sehr, sehr viele Werte drauf gelegt, dass ihr aber betont habt, na ja, das kann halt jeder machen. Darum habt ihr es euch so einfach gemacht.
Wie ich schon sagte, wir wollten gar nicht irgendwie da sehr in die technischen Details reingehen, weil dann müssten wir automatisch irgendwie bestimmte Hersteller angreifen mit unseren Ideen und natürlich auch in der Öffentlichkeit, wenn man das dann irgendwie mal vorstellt. Warum sollte man sich diese Arbeit machen, wenn man eigentlich nur an der Oberfläche kratzen muss und da halt auch schon eine ganze Menge zusammenfällt.
Das ist vielleicht auch eher eine sinnvolle Sache. Man muss sich überlegen, für wen man sich Angriffe ausdenkt. Sollte man eher so denken, wie so ein Kleinkriminaler denken würde und versuchen, ihm den einfachsten möglichen und preiswerten Weg zu finden oder sich halt hinsetzen, sich mit dem Schiff befassen. Das dauert ja sicherlich viele Monate und man muss auch bedenken, für die deutsche Version hatten wir ja auch nur den Prototyp. Irgendwann mal gucken, ob er auch so bleibt. Man muss immer noch mal sehen, dass wir hier in Deutschland ja weit vor der Einführung sind. Warum sollte man sich also die Mühe machen, wenn so einfache Dinge quasi auf der Straße liegen?
Ok, also das Ziel ist quasi, möglichst schnell an so ein Ding mal ranzukommen. Was genau habt ihr denn jetzt gemacht?
Im Endeffekt haben wir... was haben wir gemacht?
Technisch? Willst du das jetzt technisch wissen?
Nein, nein, also dieses Ding ist ja irgendwie dazu da. Es gibt diesen elektronischen Personalausweis, den kann ich auf so ein Lesegerät legen, dann gebe ich meine PIN ein und dann weiß die Gegenstelle im Internet, okay, das ist der Markus. Und ihr habt damit irgendwas angestellt, was sozusagen nicht der Zweck ist, den das Ding eigentlich hat. Nämlich?
Vielleicht versuchen wir mal zu erklären, wo wir überhaupt den Angriff angesetzt haben. Ich habe ja vorhin kurz über diese drei Ebenen gesprochen. Und uns ging es hier in erster Linie um diese zweite Ebene, also die elektronische ID. Aber natürlich haben wir uns auch Gedanken gemacht über die elektronische Signatur, die dann ja der dritte Bereich wäre.
Also quasi meine Unterschriften im Internet.
Genau. Aber für den deutschen Bereich hatten wir ja da keine Testumgebung, weil es ja einfach noch nicht möglich ist, das mal durchzuführen. Und so haben wir uns für diese elektronische Signatur auf die SuisseID beschränkt. Aber natürlich haben wir uns überlegt, welche von diesen Angriffen tatsächlich auch einfach durchzuführen wären bei dem deutschen Modell. Da werden wir abwarten müssen, bis der erste November kommt.
Okay, dann fangen wir mal mit der ID an.
Ja, im Endeffekt haben wir uns einfach mal diese altbekannten Angriffsmethoden hergenommen, die von Fishing-Leuten, also irgendwelchen Leuten, die jetzt so Online-Banking-Betrügereien begehen, haben wir uns im Endeffekt aber bedient. Und da muss ich auch noch sagen, da gibt es ja auch unterschiedlich komplexe Angriffsvarianten. Und die bedienen sich in der Regel, das sagt halt irgendwie so die Statistik oder was man eben davon kennt. Das sind doch eigentlich die banalsten Geschichten. Also zum Beispiel einfach Social Engineering, dass man einfach nur E-Mails verschickt und die Leute auffordert, ihre PIN und mehrere Tanz irgendwo einzugeben.
Entschuldigung, ihr Bankkonto wurde gesperrt, geben sie ihre PIN ein.
Naja, aber das ist eben ein sehr einfacher Angriff. Dagegen kann man sich natürlich auch nur durch Denken schützen. Aber ich meine, warum sollten sich diese Angreifer, die Mühe machen, irgendwie hochtechnisch irgendwas zu implementieren? Wenn zwei von hundert Angriffen auf die als bekannte Methode Erfolg haben, das reicht ja völlig aus.
Also was genau habt ihr gemacht? Ihr könnt ja keine Mails verschickt haben, weil es hat ja noch keiner diesen EPA.
Nein, also wir haben für eine Angriffsvariante einfach mal angenommen, dass ein PC grundsätzlich unsicher ist. Das kann jeder nachvollziehen, der sich so ein bisschen mit der Thematik auskennt. Wir können gerne versuchen, das irgendwie zu erläutern, wenn es da konkrete Nachfrage gibt. Also ein PC an sich, wir haben ein bisschen Speicher. Da laufen irgendwelche Programme, die werden in den Hauptspeicher geladen und diese Programme können modifiziert werden zur Laufzeit. Und das kann halt einfach durch ein Trojaner passieren, durch irgendein Rootkit, irgendeine Schadsoftware, die man sich mal so einfängt. Da gibt es auch wieder unterschiedliche Varianten. Da gibt es die, die bekannt sind, wo dann aber vielleicht ein Viren-Scanner outdated ist und da nicht Alarm schlägt oder eben Zero-Day-Exploit oder irgendwelche Sachen, die einfach unbekannt sind, die man sich dann auch nicht schützen kann.
Sicherheitsglücken von denen noch keiner weiß. Im Prinzip seid ihr davon ausgegangen, ich habe jetzt diesen EPA und ich habe einen Rechner, der infiziert ist, wie es einfach da draußen öfter mal passiert. Was sind die Konsequenzen davon?
Wir haben das auch getan, wir haben der auch mal vorgeführt. Wir hatten also einen PC, der den Opfer darstellen sollte und da war natürlich die Schadsoftware drauf. Wir wollten das auch vorführen.
Wir wollten da vorführen, dass wir von einem entfernten Rechner diese Smartcard verwenden können, also diesen kryptographischen Token, um da mit zum Beispiel digitale Signaturen zu tätigen oder aber auch eine Transaktion durchzuführen oder zumindest zu manipulieren. Denn der Hauptaugenmerk lag darauf, remote. Die Hersteller von diesen Lösungen behaupten immer, dass man physikalischen Zugriff auf diese Karte haben muss. Und das ist einfach mal nicht wahr. Und das war eigentlich das, was wir in erster Linie auch demonstrieren wollten, mit sehr einfachen Mädchen, dass es jeder nachvollziehen kann. Denn es ist absolut falsch, zu behaupten, dass man diese Karte besitzen muss. Das ist also nicht richtig.
Jetzt hat er bei dieser ID, haben leider die Lesegeräte eine große Rolle gespielt. Der gab ja sozusagen nicht nur jetzt in dem konkreten Fall, sondern zwei Wochen vorher auch schon mal einen kleinen Aufreger. Was genau hat das damit jetzt auf sich?
Na, das war so, dass wir für den, das war ungefähr so dreieinhalb Wochen vorher, hatten wir den WDR bei uns im Club, die auch über den IP, also den ikonischen Personalausweis berichten wollen. Da ging es noch nicht an die SwissID, sondern eben um den deutschen Passausweis. Na und die haben uns gefragt, was es eigentlich für einfache Angriffe gibt. Und wir haben da schon mal gezeigt, dass man auf eine einfache Weise die PIN ausspionieren kann. Man kann nicht mehr fahren, dass man einfach den Rechner des Opfers angreift. Allerdings hatten wir keinen Einfluss darauf, dass die Sendung, bei der gesendet wurde, war damals plus minus in der ARD, daraus eine große Nachricht macht. Und der Club an sich hat sich überhaupt nicht dazu geäußert. Denn die Fakten, die da dargestellt wurden, waren ziemlich wischiwaschi. Der Beitrag im Fernsehen war natürlich eher rentnergerecht. Das heißt, keine technischen Spezifikationen.
Aber eine Sensation.
Ja, das war sehr sensationsheischend. Und darauf sind aber wir dann nochmal auf die ARD zugegangen, etwas später und haben ihnen gesagt, naja, wir wollen das gerne mal tatsächlich vorführen. Und wir haben sozusagen eigentlich noch eine zweite Variante, weil ja die SuisseID doch noch ein bisschen unterschiedlich ist. Und wir wollen das auch wirklich praktisch zeigen. Und das ist dann auch passiert, schon ein paar Monate später. Und dann haben eigentlich auch wir als Club uns überhaupt erst geäußert. Dann haben wir auch eine etwas längere Pressemitteilung geschrieben. Dann ist es auch ein bisschen auf internationalere Ebene gekommen. Also da das im Bericht aus Brüssel diesmal gesendet wurde, weil wir unsererseits uns geäußert haben, aber weil es doch offenbar ja auch durchaus auf europäischer Ebene angekommen ist. Denn diese Angriffe sind durchaus auch für andere Identitätsdokumente, die virtuell benutzt werden sollen, möglich. Und es ist ja nicht unbedingt so, dass die Deutschen oder die Schweizer machen ganz seltene Lösungen wären, sondern viele europäische Länder haben ja ähnliche Sachen. Und insofern ist es diesmal auch anders angekommen. Und wir haben von unserer Seite auch versucht, mit einer bisschen längeren Meldung die Details zu klären. Natürlich ist uns klar, und das haben wir auch gemerkt bei der Berichterstattung, dass nachher Journalisten manchmal gar nicht große Lesen haben, sondern eigentlich nur den Fernsehbericht gesehen haben. Und der hat nur einen kleinen Bruchteil von dem, was wir eigentlich gezeigt haben, später gesendet.
Also da lernt man schon mal irgendwie, wenn man als politisch interessierter Hacker unterwegs ist, muss man auch ein bisschen Medienpolitik machen, damit das alles funktioniert. Aber mal zurück zu dem, also bei beiden Dagen ging es ja darum zu sagen, es gibt einen Rechner, der ist von einem Virus befallen, und dann liegt irgendwie diese Karte in diesem Lesegerät, und dann kann man damit Unfug treiben.
Ja, das war einfach mal eine Voraussetzung, die wir natürlich so betroffen haben. Also der Rechner ist infiziert mit irgendeinem Torianer-Hoodkit, oder es gibt einen Man-in-the-Mittel-Angriff, oder einen Man-in-the-Browser. Das sind halt so einfach Möglichkeiten, dass sich ein Angreifer noch in die Kommunikation so mit einhängt und dann da irgendwie Daten in beide Richtungen im Endeffekt manipulieren kann.
Das war eigentlich auch tatsächlich dann für die Funktionalitäten, die bei beiden angeboten werden, also bei der SuisseID und beim deutschen Ausweis, die haben wir einfach mal durchgeführt. Wir wollten also gucken, ob wir mit dem Angreifer-Rechner, der in einem anderen Netz war, tatsächlich das auch machen können. Und da war bei dem Ausweis natürlich sehr naheliegend, dass wir geguckt haben, können wir erstmal die PIN ändern zum Beispiel.
Einer der wenigen Features, die wir überhaupt zur Verfügung hatten.
Genau, da ist ja noch nicht so sehr viel zum probieren. Das hat sofort funktioniert, mit meinem allerersten Versuch. Das war selbst für uns ein bisschen überraschend, müssen wir mal ehrlicherweise sagen, dass es so schnell funktioniert hat. Wir hätten ja etwas mehr Gegenwehr erwartet.
Im Endeffekt haben wir ja über das Netzwerk, dieses komplette USB-Gerät übernommen.
Also dieses Lesegerät.
Genau, das Lesegerät und da drin steckt halt die Karte und dagegen kann man sich dann im Endeffekt gar nicht schützen.
Okay, das ist genau der Punkt. Ich habe auch ein paar Reaktionen draußen gesehen. Da war ich jetzt genau so, naja gut, der Chaos Computer Club macht jetzt Panik, weil infizierte Computer und EPA, aber letztendlich meine Güte, Computer sind halt infiziert. Das war so bei manchen Leuten die Reaktion. Was ihr dazu zu sagen habt, das klären wir gleich. Dann gilt auch anrufen 0331 70 97 110. Heute Chaos Radio in Blue Moon, das heißt Chaos Radio. Der Chaos Computer Club ist zu Besuch und nimmt heute den elektronischen Personalausweis und etwas, was so ähnlich funktioniert, nämlich die SuisseID auseinander. Wir haben gerade schon darüber gesprochen, was das ist, wie es funktionieren soll. Und dass ihr sozusagen jetzt nicht irgendwie nach neuen, derbe komplizierten Sicherheitslücken in dem System gesucht habt, sondern einfach mal euch den Kleinkriminellen vorgestellt habt, der irgendwie so, hey, ich will auch mal mit dem EPA von anderen Leuten spielen gemacht habt. Und das hat auch sehr gut funktioniert. Jetzt gibt es Leute, die draußen sagen, Leute, die draußen sagen, da fällt mir ein, die solltet ihr anrufen 0331 70 97 110. Ihr könnt Fragen stellen, die ihr zum elektronischen Personalausweis habt. Ihr könnt Kritik anmerken, wenn ihr mit der Position vor dem CCC nicht fein, wie heißt das, einverstanden seid oder ihr könnt lobhudeln, ganz wie ihr wollt. Wir haben auch im Wiki zur Sendung, das ihr alles unter chaosradio.de findet. Ganz, ganz, ganz viele Fragen sind da zusammengetragen worden. Wir werden uns bemühen, dass wir die heute irgendwie noch beantworten können. Also die Sendung gehört quasi nicht nur dem Chaos Computer Club, sondern auch euch. Ihr könnt jetzt hier mitmachen. Aber erste Frage an euch zuerst nochmal. Es gibt, wie gesagt, draußen eine Position. Na ja gut, Rechner sind halt infiziert, es passiert. Und dann kann man halt auch mal so einen Elektronen-Sperr, eine Personalausweis übernehmen. Was ist daran so schlimm?
Na ja, wir haben da schon eine sehr klare Position. Das eine ist, wir erwarten natürlich eigentlich von der ausgebenden Institution, egal ob in der Schweiz oder in Deutschland, dass diejenigen, die diese Dokumente bekommen, diese digitale, neue Dokument aufgeklärt werden über die Risiken. Und bei uns in Deutschland ist es so, hier wurde einfach quasi festgelegt, der Rechner, der diesen Ausweis besitzt, der ist sicher, so per Default, wird einfach mal angenommen. Und dahinter bauen wir unser Konzept. Und ähnlich läuft es in der Schweiz ja auch.
Und dann gibt es noch ein paar kluge Tipps, um sich dann auch abzusichern. Dann heißt es ja, installiere auf jeden Fall einen Vian-Scanner und eine Firewall. Aber da steht dann halt auch nicht, wie genau. Also ich habe mich jetzt auch gefragt, was für einen Vian-Scanner, für einen Mac OS oder für einen Linux empfiehlt denn das BSI zum Beispiel. Oder was für eine Personal Firewall soll ich denn da so verwenden? Soll ich mich auf die verlassen meines Plastik-DSL-Router-Herstellers? Oder brauche ich noch eine andere?
Aber ihr seid doch von CCC, könnt ihr nicht selber eine schreiben?
Na ja, geht glaube ich eher weniger um uns. Wir haben da tatsächlich so eine Art aufklärerische Interesse, weil wir denken natürlich auch immer, es geht jetzt hier nicht nur um eine technische Community, die irgendwie Lust hat, mal wieder was auszuprobieren, sondern es ist ein Projekt für die gesamte Bevölkerung.
Sicherlich könnten wir damit gut umgehen mit diesem Personalausweis, aber es geht ja nicht um uns, es geht irgendwie um die ganzen anderen Leute, die das Ding verwenden.
Aber das, sagen wir mal zu einer interessanten Frage, es geht jetzt nicht darum, dass das Produkt oder die Idee, wir haben eine elektronische ID, mit der wir uns im Internet ausweisen, generell schlecht ist.
Und so suggeriert, dass diese Dinge jetzt irgendwie alles sicher macht und das ist völliger Quatsch.
Also jetzt die Position, wir haben ja auch schließlich eine sehr direkte Reaktion bekommen. Das ist ein sogenanntes White Paper, das das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationszeichnung rausgegeben hat, also der technische Dienstleister der Bundesrepublik. Und hier wird zwar der CCC nicht erwähnt, aber sie erwähnen die Debatten um die Sicherheit des Personalausweises. Und hier gibt es schon klare Reaktionen. Aber hier sind natürlich auch Hinweise in diesem White Paper, wo wir erneut fragen müssen, was die da wohl rauchen. Denn da sind so eine Hinweise drin, wie dass man eben möglichst, wenn man den Ausweis benutzt hat, doch schnell die Karte wieder vom Lesegerät nimmt. Da sind wieder mal Hinweise auf Virenscanner und Firewalls. Das ist natürlich, das wird meiner Mutter nur nicht wirklich helfen, wenn sie sich einsetzen würde. Und da ist auch wieder der Hinweis, egal, dass man die billigen Lesegeräte sehr leicht angreifen kann, es wäre ja immer noch ein Sicherheitsgewinn gegenüber der heutigen Situation. Da sind wir schon anderer Meinung.
Das ist einfach nicht den Tatsachen entsprechen. Vor allen Dingen wird auch wieder in diesen Tipps suggeriert, dass der Einsatz von einer Firewall und einem Virenscanner jetzt wieder alles super sicher macht. Das ist das Problem, was wir sowieso jeden Tag sehen, wenn wir mit Leuten diskutieren, die da nicht ganz so fit sind. Die sagen so, was soll mir passieren, ich habe einen Virenscanner, ich habe eine Firewall, so what?
Wahrscheinlich ist es egal, für viele von eher wenig technikaffinen Leuten wird die Installation der Ausweis-App schon die Hürde sein, die nicht mehr übersprungen werden kann. Wir hatten ja auch die Gelegenheit, mal so vor einer Benutzbarkeit der Software damit zu spielen. War ein großer Spaß, wahrscheinlich scheitern sie schon daran. Aber hier gibt es halt wieder so die typischen Hinweise, wo eigentlich die BSI an anderer Stelle sehr wohl, sehr klar warnt vor Gefahren im Netz. Aber bei den eigenen Projekten ganz offenbar eine politische Linie fährt. Also hier werden halt Aussagen getroffen, die technisch so eigentlich nicht haltbar sind, aber eben der politischen Linie dienen. Das ist schon bedauerlich. Da sind wir auch ein bisschen enttäuscht, weil wir eigentlich ein bisschen erwartet hätten, dass die Linie vielleicht auch sein könnte jetzt okay. Wir erkennen diese Sicherheitslücke an, die wird auch anerkannt. In dem White Paper hat es schon so, dass klar ist, dass was wir da getan haben auch tatsächlich möglich ist und auch einfach möglich ist. Aber eigentlich müsste doch die Konsequenz sein, dass bei der Ausgabe dieses Ausweises statt einer Lobhudelei-Broschüre eine ernsthafte Broschüre steht, die auf die Gefahren hinweist.
Das ist ja unsere zentrale Forderung.
Also, dass man sagt, wie Risiken und Nebenwirkungen des elektronischen Personalausweises sind. Okay, ihr habt jetzt auch gerade irgendwie von dem sicheren und dem unsicheren Lesegerät gesprochen. Das müssen wir auch noch klären, sonst wird das ja auch noch nur so ein Wischi waschen. Und wir haben ja nur zwei Stunden Zeit. Vorher aber nehmen wir den Tim, der hat nämlich eine Frage. Tag Tim. Was ist deine Frage zum Ausweis?
Also die erste Frage, welche Wiese, was kostet der?
Das ist ziemlich einfach, kostet knapp 30 Euro. Also ein bisschen weniger als 30 Euro. Das ist schon ein etwas stärkerer Anstieg. Heute kostet er so acht in der Regel. Aber die Technik ist natürlich auch nicht ganz billig. Und das muss auch jeder bezahlen, der nicht einsetzen will. Nein, wenn man einen Ausweis haben will, was man nicht muss in Deutschland. Aber wenn man einen beantragt, dann muss man die auch zahlen. Egal, ob man diese elektronische Identität oder die qualifizierte Signatur haben will. Man zahlt für die Signatur nochmal drauf. Da sind noch andere Kosten, die entstehen. Und Lesegeräte muss man auch extra erstehen, wenn man es nicht geschenkt bekommt. Und da sind jetzt wohl so eine Million Geräte gekauft worden, die will man auch nicht geschenkt bekommen.
Okay, das wollen wir gleich nochmal erklären, was die sicheren und unsicheren oder bzw. sicheren und weniger sicheren sind. Das führt uns gleich noch zu der Frage, die im Wiki steht, nämlich wie lange habe ich denn noch Zeit mit einem alten Personalausweis zu holen, falls ich keine 30 Euro bezahlen will?
Man kann auch bis Ende Oktober einen alten Ausweis beantragen. Das würden wir natürlich auch jedem empfehlen, nicht nur weil es extrem viel billiger ist, sondern weil er noch dieses andere kleine Detail ist, denn der neue Ausweis hat natürlich nicht nur diese Inditätsfunktion, sondern er ist auch biometrisch. Das heißt, mit dem neuen Ausweis ab 1. November wird man verpflichtet, ein biometrisches, digitales Frontalgesichts-Bit abzugeben. Also es wird digitalisiert, man kann es als normales Passbitt abgeben, auf dem man nicht lächeln darf, und man kann auch die erkennungsdienstliche Behandlung durchführen lassen mit Fingerabdrücken.
Kann man oder muss man?
Optional.
Ne, eine habe ich noch. Und zwar, ich müsste jetzt meinen neuen Ausweis wieder abholen. Jetzt ist aber die Frage, bekomme ich gleich schon den neuen oder noch den alten?
Kannst du eigentlich selber beantworten, musstest du schon biometerschuld Bild abgeben, und was hast du bezahlt, und dann weißt du, dass du eigentlich nur einen alten kriegen kannst. Denn der neue wird eben tatsächlich erst ab 1.
Da ich Papieranfänger bin, braucht sich gar nichts zahlen.
Ah, ok, du hast so einen Sozialzuschuss-Dings da, ne? Richtig. Nee, der kriegst du aber auf jeden Fall einen alten.
Würdest du dir jetzt, wenn du die Wahl hättest, würdest du dir einen neuen holen? Also ich meine, wenn es dir quasi bezahlt wird und es eigentlich egal ist?
Ich weiß ja noch nicht, wie der neue aussieht. Die können ja noch nicht irgendwie sehen.
Ok, aber von dem, was du bis jetzt gehört hast, ist es dir erstmal egal?
Ja, vom Prinzip her schon.
Alles klar. Tim, ich empfehle, die Sendung zu ändern und zu hören. Dann hast du vielleicht eine deutliche Antwort auf diese Frage. Wo wir gerade bei den Leuten sind, die 033177, 97110 gewählt haben, nehmen wir gleich noch den Fabian dazu. Hallo Fabian. Hallöchen.
Ich habe den Ausweis jetzt vor etwa ein bis zwei Wochen nochmal beantragt. Das heißt, ich bekomme jetzt in Kürze den alten Ausweis nochmal.
Warum hast du das getan?
Ich habe das getan, nicht nur weil es günstiger ist, sondern weil ich auch denke, dass der neue Ausweis einfach mit der Version 10 und 1.0 sehr viele Kindheitsprobleme hat. Und den will ich mich nicht unbedingt aussetzen. Also ich denke schon prinzipiell, dass ich so einen Ausweis in der Form gestalten ließe, dass zumindest derartige Sicherheitsrisiken, wie sie jetzt derzeit da sind, sich verhindern lassen. Also anders als bei Wahlcomputern denke ich, dass es systematisch zumindest möglich wäre, die Teile sicher zu machen. Aber da bleibt natürlich immer noch das Problem bestehen, dass man sich irgendwie bei einem zentralen Computer seine Verifikation abholen muss. Also da muss dann irgendwo ein Bundesrechner stehen, den das Lesegerät irgendwie anspricht. Und der muss dann halt irgendwie doch zentral alle Ausweisdaten haben.
Okay, zwei Fragen an die Leute hier im Studio. Erstens ist es in der Tat möglich, so ein System in sich herzugeschalten oder zumindest so sicher, dass ihr sagen würdet, okay, benutze es mal und zweitens gibt es einen zentralen Computer für den elektronischen Personalausweis?
Also erstmal will ich das überhaupt nicht ausschließen, dass man so ein System auch hinreichend sicher bekommt. Das ist halt im Moment nicht der Fall. Es gibt halt, wie ihr sagt selbst, einfach noch sehr viele Kinderkrankheiten. Ich meine, wir wollen das jetzt auch nicht verteufeln oder so. Es ist ja, zum Teil gibt es ja auch einige Features, die ja so ganz schön sind. Das ist halt irgendwie zeitgemäß und so weiter. Und manche Features will man ja vielleicht auch haben, aber den Risiken muss man sich einfach bewusst sein. Und wenn man mehr Sicherheit möchte, dann bedeutet das einfach mehr Aufwand und mehr Kosten. Und das muss man einfach irgendwann akzeptiert haben.
Ich glaube, das gilt eigentlich für alle technischen Systeme. Das haben wir glaube ich auch bei vielen anderen Themen, die der Club so ein bisschen bearbeitet dargestellt. Na klar ist das möglich. Das ist halt am Ende auch eine Abwägung zwischen Geld und Aufwand. Und für 30 Euro ist es sicherlich schwierig. Deswegen die sichere Variante ja jetzt ohnehin schon 150 oder 200 Euro kostet. Weil man sich einfach ein teueres Lesegerät zu dem Kumpel ja nachher nochmal kaufen muss und mehr investieren muss. Und für die Signature muss man sogar noch ein bisschen mehr investieren. Insofern, es ist in allen Systemen, die mit IT-Security zu tun haben, auch immer eine Abwägung. Und hier hat sich der Staat dann schlau entschieden. Er hat nämlich einfach die Sicherheitsprobleme beim Bürger abgeladen. Der dann auch das Problem hat, wenn jemand Fremdes mit seinem Ausweis oder mit seiner SuisseID Schindluder treibt. Das ist einfach ziemlich einfach geregelt. Da hat der Gesetzgeber gesagt, naja, unsere Annahme ist der PC oder auch der Mobiltelefon, das würde in gleicher Weise gelten, die benutzt werden, um diese Identitätsdokumente virtuell zu benutzen. Die sind sicher TM.
Also festgelegt. Also was ich ja in dieser Erwiderung des BSI gelesen habe, geht noch mal weiter. Da steht auch in der Rechtsprechung, wird eine Pflicht des Nutzers zur angemessenen Sicherung eines am Internet angeschlossenen Rechners bestätigt. Das hört sich für mich so an, als ob sie mir das in die Schuhe schieben, also dass sie nicht sagen, okay, das System ist auf jeden Fall sicher, sondern als ob sie sagen, du bist selber dafür verantwortlich.
Das Landgericht Köln hat gesagt, du musst dich selber darum kümmern, also mach mal.
Ist das der Fall jetzt sozusagen, also quasi die Linie, die da langfristig gefahren wird?
Nein, das ist natürlich nicht in jedem Fall richtig. Da muss man natürlich noch mal sehen, dass es hier noch was anderes ist, als wenn ein zum Beispiel ein privater Anbieter, in der Schweiz sind es ja private Anbieter, solche virtuellen Lösungen für Authentifizierung anbietet, oder ob es der Staat ist. Ich denke, dass der Staat natürlich andere Pflichten hat, wenn er Gesetze ausgestaltet und die Bürger verpflichtet. Und sogar eben die Bürger, die das gar nicht haben wollen, dann ist ja sozusagen der Preis, den alle zahlen. Das ist noch mal ein Unterschied zu der Schweiz, wo der von privaten Unternehmen angeboten wird. Aber festzulegen, so wie das jetzt hier mit diesem Landgerichtsurteil, in diesem White Paper drin steht, dass der Bürger darum kümmern muss, das ist natürlich Unsinn.
Okay, also ist es Unsinn, weil ihr das sagt oder kommt das auch nicht auf uns zu?
Na ja, also erstmal eine Landgerichtsmeinung Köln, die einen speziellen Fall betrifft, hat natürlich keine Aussagekraft für so eine größeren Projekte.
Alles klar, was Fabian dann noch gesagt hat, ist ja, es gibt einen elektronischen Rechner, der alle unsere Daten speichert. Was gibt es da?
Ist das nicht richtig, dass es diese Bundeszentralregister irgendwie geben soll? Natürlich sind da Gedankenspiele, Gedankenspiele waren da schon mal im Umlauf. Derzeit ist es so, dass die Daten natürlich auf den Meldeämtern anfallen, klar. Und sie werden natürlich auch an die Bundesdruckerei übertragen, denn die sind ja die Hersteller dieses Personalausweises. Die sollen aber gelöscht werden, nachdem das Dokument ausgestellt wird. Aber in den Meldeämtern liegt natürlich eine Kopie der Daten, die auf dem Ausweis sind.
Aber Fabian, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, dann kannst du doch so sagen, dass bei der Abfrage, wenn man den Ausweis benutzt, dass da irgendwas Zentrales passiert. Kannst du nochmal stellen, die Frage?
Also bei der Abfrage muss ich ja irgendwie mit einem Rechner verbunden werden, der dann meinen Ausweis verifizieren kann. Und der wird ja nicht nur meinen Ausweis da verifizieren können, sondern direkt eine Reihe von anderen ausweisen. Und wenn man einen solchen Rechner irgendwie dann angreifen kann, denn alles, was am Netz angeschlossen ist, ist ja auch irgendwo angreifbar, dann hätte man über einen gewissen Zeitraum sicherlich auch die Möglichkeit, direkt eine ganze Reihe von Verifizierungen zu tätigen, die nicht legitim wären.
Also du willst jetzt quasi den Angriff, den wir auf die Seite der Bürger gezeigt haben, also auf dem Rechner, den der Bürger benutzt, der den Ausweis hat, du willst jetzt sozusagen auf die Seite der Anbieter wechseln und die Rechner angreifen, die die Zertifikatebesitzer, also die Diensteanbieter, Versicherungen oder Banken haben. Ich glaube, da wird es dann deutlich einfacher, den Benutzer PC anzugreifen.
Du nimmst jetzt an, dass...
Aber das war jetzt auch nur eine Annahme, dass man, selbst wenn man den jetzigen Ausweis so gestaltet hätte, dass das so sicher wäre, selbst dann gibt es ja noch andere Möglichkeiten, das zu kompromittieren und zu unterwandern.
Du nimmst jetzt an, dass es irgendwie einen zentralen Server gibt, wo sich dann im Endeffekt diese ganzen Benutzer dann authentifizieren oder wie?
Ich nehme an, dass es für irgendwie eine gewisse Reihe von Ausweisungen dann zumindest einen Server geben wird, wo ich mich habe.
Das funktioniert hier über eine kryptographische Lösung, also eine Public-Key-Infrastruktur. Und darüber findet dann im Endeffekt so eine Authentifizierung von Benutzern statt. Also es ist eigentlich kein zentraler Server. Das heißt, man kann nicht einen zentralen Server angreifen und dann alle Bürger kompromittieren.
Dann hätte ich aber noch eine andere Frage. Ist denn bekannt, wer diesen Chip herstellt? Nach dem, was ich erfahren habe, war das ja bei dem Reisepass in Finien. Ist das irgendwie bekannt bisher?
In der Schweiz zum Beispiel ist das total super. Da kann man einfach eine E-Mail schicken an diesen Support. Das haben wir heute auch getan. Und die haben dann nach zahlreichen Nachfragen die Details rausgerückt. Die mussten auch immer wieder weiter nachfragen. Kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, ich melde mich später nochmal. Aber es hat geklappt. Das ist genau so ein Teil, so ein SLE 66. Das kam ganz offiziell von Quo Vadis, dem Support für diese Swiss-ID-Geschichten.
Wer denn die genaue Bezeichnung sucht, findet die auch auf www.ccc.de. Weil wir haben die genaue Bezeichnung des Ships, da aufzustehen in unserer Pressemitteilung zu dem, zu dem, zu der Swiss-ID. Auch da ist mittlerweile klar, aber auch noch nicht allzu lange. Und ich habe glaube ich gesagt, im Monat ist klar, welcher Chip es genau sein wird. Ich habe den aber ehrlich gesagt nicht im Kopf. Wann wird den denn z.B.? Auch nicht. Naja, also soweit ich weiß, war ein NXP. Aber ich habe es nicht im Kopf, da ich jetzt gerade kein Netz habe und kein Chat kann ich auch nicht fragen. Aber es ist im CCC bekannt. Ich glaube, es ist ein NXP-Ship.
Das interessiert aber auch für diese Angriffe, die wir hier thematisieren, überhaupt gar nicht.
Es geht darum, dass man, wenn man das einmal überwunden hätte, diese Risiken, also dass dann immer noch irgendwo was wäre. Ich meine, es gab ja z.B. in der Chaosradio Express Sendung 98 den Mifi-Hack.
Ja, genau.
Den fand ich auch super. Wo dann der Ship bis auf das letzte halt voreinander genommen wurde.
Jetzt musst du aber mal kurz erklären für alle Leute, die das Chaosradio Express nicht gehört haben, was genau da passiert ist.
Ja, das war ein RFID-Ship, also eine RFID-Karte. Und den Ship, den haben, ich weiß nicht mehr wie genau das war, ich glaube da war irgendwie Erdgeist dran beteiligt. Der hat das so weit aufgehobelt, dass der da bis an den Silizium-Waver dran ist und dann über mikroskopische Verfahren dann eben ermittelt hat, wie da die Gatter aufgebaut sind und dann den Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus auf die Weise geklagt hat.
Man nennt das eigentlich Aufschleifen oder Abschleifen. Das heißt, Schicht für Schicht nimmt man diesen Chip, also man macht ihn quasi nackig.
Genau. Das ist eine Sache, da hast du natürlich völlig recht, das sind auch nochmal Angriffszenarien, die haben wir hier auch nicht berücksichtigt, dass das halt wieder sehr technisch ist. Wir haben es, also Max und ich haben halt einen Vortrag gemacht zu diesem Thema jetzt vor kurzem in Zürich auf so einer Security-Konferenz, da haben wir das auch angesprochen, weil wir natürlich auch einfach nochmal auf diese Aussage dieser Chip-Hersteller eingehen wollten, die behaupten, unser Chip ist unknackbar und überhaupt, den kriegt man nie kaputtgehackt. Wir haben halt einfach gerade, wo es eben um diesen SLE66 geht, der da in der SuisseID versteckt ist, da haben wir einfach mal ganz konkrete, frische Aufnahmen gehabt von Leuten, die das in ihrem Wohnzimmer zu Hause aufätzen. Die haben da super tolle Fotos gemacht mit so einem Elektronenmikroskop, schön vergrößert und die konnten wir dann halt auch zeigen. Und konnten einfach sagen, okay, und wo ist dieser Chip jetzt noch sicher? Also ich sehe jedes Detail, ich kann irgendwie sämtliche H-Kadrate...
Herr Einspruch, euer Ehren, am Anfang der Sendung ging es darum, dass ihr sozusagen die Methoden der Kleinkriminellen gemacht habt, jetzt im Wohnzimmer ätzt und mit Elektronenmikroskop verlasst.
Das ist keine Kleinkriminellen-Vorgehen.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall, das gehört einfach dazu. Das ist immer noch eine Möglichkeit, die man im Zweifelsfall hat. Und da möchte ich auch nachher noch was zu sagen. Denn das ist eben dieser physikalische Zugriff auf dieses Teil. Was ist nämlich, wenn mir so ein Ding mal abhanden kommt oder einfach geklaut wird von jemandem, der einfach auch Geld investiert, um meine Identität zu bekommen? Kann man vielleicht später nachher noch...
Wir sind gerade schon dabei, sagen wir. Also einerseits hochtechnisch, irgendwie mit Elektronenmikroskop, andererseits im Wohnzimmer. Wie einfach ist das denn jetzt? Wie viele Leute kennst du persönlich, die zu so was in der Lage sind?
Also die Sache ist, wenn das einer mal getan hat, dann ist das ja bekannt. Dann ist es ja tatsächlich gezeigt worden. Wer das nachlesen kann, wir haben es auch gut dokumentiert. Also man kann sich zum Beispiel die letzte Datenschleuder, die auch online ist, holen, die Nummer 94, wo die Nummer genau beschrieben ist. Der Punkt ist, dass man das natürlich, wenn das veröffentlicht wird, nicht nochmal selber tun muss, sondern man kann sich die Erkenntnisse, die jemand anders darüber gewonnen hat, dann ja holen. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass man das jedes Mal durchführen muss. Es reicht eigentlich, wenn das für einen Chip einer mal getan hat.
Also es hat vor kurzem eben der Chris Tarnowski aus USA auf der BlackHat-Konferenz präsentiert, wie er den SLE 66 aufgemacht hat.
Also genau den Chip.
Also genau den Chip. Wer sich das irgendwie auch nochmal nachvollziehen möchte, der kann einfach mal auf der Chaosradio-Seite in die Linkliste gucken. Da gibt es einen Link auf unserer Webseite www.remoteexploit.org. Da haben wir unsere Slides auch zum runterladen. Da haben wir auch diese Screenshots, also diese Fotos von diesem Chip drin, wie er aufgemacht wurde. Also einfach um, das haben wir in die Slides einfach reingetan, damit wir all diesen ganzen Leuten, denen wir das präsentieren, einfach zeigen, hier, okay, wo ist jetzt die Sicherheit? Das ist einfach nur eine Frage der Zeit. Auch wenn dieser Chip die allerneuesten Merkmale besitzt, die es einfach erschweren. Also es sind ja nur Hürden. Wir reden ja hier nicht von 100-prozentiger Sicherheit, sondern von Hürden, die da eingebaut werden, von proprietärer Krypto, die da hart verdrahtet wird, um irgendetwas zu verschleiern, was da gespeichert ist. Also es ist einfach nur eine Frage der Zeit, dass das von irgendjemandem mal gebrochen wird. In fünf Jahren kann ja sein, wenn das heute nicht möglich ist, kann es ja sein, dass in fünf Jahren die technischen Mittel, die man als Privatmensch zur Verfügung hat, so ausgereift sind, damit man das Ding einfach aufmacht. Und dann stellt sich natürlich die Frage, was passiert in fünf Jahren mit unserer elektronischen Unterschrift, wenn irgendwie die Leute in der Lage sind, mit sehr einfachen technischen Mitteln in sehr kurzer Zeit, mit geringem Aufwand, also vor allen Dingen finanziellen Aufwand, eine Identität von uns zu klonen.
Also wenn ich das mit dem Chip aufmache, dann ist der nicht danach kaputt, sondern ich kann danach den sozusagen weiterverwenden.
Du möchtest das Prinzip ergründen. Du willst nicht jeden einzelnen Chip, du musst einen dieses Typs ergründen.
Weil da gerade von einem Klonen gesprochen wurde.
Nee, du kannst dann schon dahergehen und sagen, ich klone mir halt so einen ganz bestimmten Chip von. Also einfach der Typ da, der hat irgendwie, weiß ich, wie viele Milliarden auf dem Konto. Und da lade ich mir einfach mal seinen Perso aus für einen Tag oder zwei. Und dann kann ich den vielleicht klonen und kann ihm vielleicht wieder eine Chipkarte herstellen, die eh so ähnlich aussieht wie sein jetziger Perso oder seine jetzige Swiss ID. Und der wird das vielleicht nicht merken. Das ist natürlich das Risiko, dass er das bemerkt. Dass das vielleicht irgendwie ein Klon ist oder so.
Das ist bei dem Ausweis sehr schwierig. Bei der Swiss ID ist es relativ einfach. Aber beim Ausweis ist es sehr schwierig, die äußere Formen zu fälschen.
Das ist schon jetzt so James-Bond-Style.
Ja, aber ich meine, was muss man da investieren?
Keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht.
Das ist eine konkrete Zahl, so ein Ding zu analysieren. Die Leute sagen immer...
Das ist schon eine Elektronen-Mikroskope. Die gibt es ja mittlerweile auch schon im Marke Eigenbau. Von der Uni Münster habe ich auch mal über, ich glaube, Raprap, da gab es auch mal einen Link zu, dass sowas auch gebaut werden kann mit einfachen Mitteln. Und das kostet dann weit unter 1000 Euro.
Ja, aber wenn man jetzt jemanden fragt, der das professionell und gut macht, und den fragt man, okay, hier ist ein Chip, den hast du noch nie aufgemacht, was kostet mich das jetzt, um diese Daten herauszuholen, dann wird der dir sagen, kostet 80.000 bis 100.000 Dollar. Und dann kannst du dir überlegen, ist es mir das jetzt wert, wenn ich jetzt 100.000 Dollar investiere, an diese Daten auf diesem Chip zu kommen, wenn ich anschließend durch meine Betrügerei irgendwie 2, 3 Millionen da rausziehen kann, dann ist es mir das wohl wert. Dann hat sich meine Rechnung gelohnt. Also das ist dann einfach.
Also vor allem, wenn man sich ansieht, dass diesen Ausweis ja nicht gerade mal eine geringe Anzahl von Personen bekommen soll, sondern direkt 80 Millionen.
Man weiß ja, dass ihn jeder im Endeffekt mit sich trägt, weil man braucht den Ausweis. Auch wenn er nicht gesetzlich vorgeschrieben ist, geh mal irgendwo hin und buche ein Ticket für einen Flug oder einen Zug.
Also nach dem, was ich weiß, ist der gesetzlich vorgeschrieben.
Okay, warte, jetzt nehmen wir gerade mal den André dazu. Der will nämlich genau zu diesem Thema was sagen.
Hallo André, sehr gut.
Entschuldigung, ich stand da falsch.
Das ist richtig eine sehr kuläre Vorursachtung. Ich habe auch schon zweimal und jetzt das dritte Mal gerade gehört, dass der Ausweis nicht erforderlich sein soll. Das ist nicht richtig. Also ihr, deutsche Staatsbürger, müsst so ein lustiges Personalausweis ab dem 16.
Das ist nicht richtig und wir können das auch mal gleich im Detail klären. Das ist ein weit verbreiteter...
Also ich muss ihn besitzen. Das ist ja Quatsch. Dann würde ich mir ja keinen holen. Irgendwie, was soll ich damit? Also ich muss ihn haben. Ich muss ihn als deutscher Staatsbürger nicht mitnehmen.
Nein, es geht nicht darum... Also was ich jetzt meinte, es geht nicht darum, ob man ihn mit sich herumtragen muss. Dazu ist man nicht verpflichtet, zu sagen, dass man ihn mitführt. Man muss ihn auch nicht besitzen. Man ist aber gesetzlich in Deutschland verpflichtet, ein Ausweisdokument zu haben. Das muss aber nicht der Personalausweis sein. Man kann auch stattdessen einen Reisepass haben. Der ist in gleicher Weise gültig. Es gibt auch ein paar Millionen Menschen, die keinen Personalausweis haben in Deutschland. Sondern nur den Reisepass 1 von beidem muss man aber haben. Sind wir uns ja einig.
Das ist korrekt. Man muss keinen Reisepass haben. Wenn ich das Staatsgebiet in Deutschland verlassen will, muss ich keinen Reisepass haben. Wenn ich keinen Reisepass haben will, habe ich keinen. Aber dann muss ich den Personalausweis haben.
Dann sind wir auch einzugehen.
Ich bin verpflichtet, den Reisepass für einen gewissen Preis zu holen.
Das ist richtig. Für einen von beiden musst du dich entscheiden. Du musst auch beim beiden den Preis zahlen. Natürlich ist es so, dass die Lösung für einen Reisepass elektronisiert ist. Der hat auch biometrische Merkmale. Beim Reisepass ist sowohl das frontale Gesichtsbild, wie auch die Fingerabdrücke zwingend. Da kann man sich nicht, wie beim Ausweis jetzt, aussuchen, ob man auch einen digitalen Fingerabdruck abgibt. Da gibt es nochmal einen Unterschied.
Aber das ist nicht richtig. Dann würde man da irgendwie eine Unstigkeit ausbreiten. Wenn man das Ding nicht anschafft.
Na gut, also wie gesagt, eins von beiden brauchen wir. Und im Teilhalsfall kann man sich heute noch dafür entscheiden, dass doch der Reisepass gilt, auch wenn der Chip da drin kaputt ist.
Das ist bei beiden richtig. Das sollten wir vielleicht sowieso mal erwähnen. Beim Reisepass, wie auch beim Personalausweis, ist es so, dass das physische Dokument eigentlich das Ausweisdokument ist. Das heißt, wenn der Chip kaputt geht oder aus anderen Gründen nicht mehr geht, jedenfalls nicht mehr funkt, ist es trotzdem über die gesamte Laufzeit ein gültiges Dokument. Das heißt, der Chip ist sowohl im Reisepass, wie auch im Ausweis rechtlich, aber auch faktisch nicht Teil des Dokuments.
Okay, das heißt also, ich kann einfach den neuen EPAR, gibt es also doch in der sicheren Variante? Das ist natürlich genau dann, wenn der Chip kaputt ist. Großartig! Heute Chaosradio mit Konstanze Kurz und Thorsten Schröder. Es geht um den elektronischen Personalausweis und die Swiss ID. Elektronische Personalausweis ereilt uns ab November. Wir werden gleich mal erklären, was es jetzt mit diesen komischen unterschiedlichen Lesegeräten auf sich hat. Vorher gibt es aber ein bisschen Musik. Ich versuche hier im Chaosradio immer Creative Commons Musik zu spielen und mich auch ein bisschen nach den Gästen zu richten, wenn die Musikwünsche haben und Thorsten meinte so ja Creative Commons, keine Ahnung, ich mag als Garpunk, da gibt es das. Das gibt es doch bestimmt gar nicht. Gibt es natürlich doch. Haben wir rausgefunden. Distemper heißt die Band. Die kennst du sogar, ne? Ja, kann manchmal ganz interessant sein. Ich hab's gekauft. Die Musik könnt ihr euch alle so runterladen, die wir hier spielen und den Link gibt's auf Chaosradio.de in der Mitmachseite zur Sendung. Die Sendung ist die Nummer 161 und es geht um den elektronischen Personalausweis. Und wir haben schon erklärt, wie der funktioniert, dass man sich halt im Internet damit ausweisen können soll. Und damit das alles klappt, gibt es Lesegeräte. Und da haben wir jetzt irgendwie, ihr habt schon öfter gesagt, es gibt die sicheren und die etwas sichereren und dann die unsicheren. Wie unterscheiden die sich? Was, warum gibt's da manche umsonst?
Oh, hast du mich wieder nicht angeschaltet?
Das sind eigentlich drei Klassen.
Haha, sehr lustig, Männer. Wir haben früher eigentlich diese Klassen bis zu Klasse 3 unterschieden. Heute nennen sie sich aber Basislaser, Standardleser und Komfortleser. Das heißt, die Namen wurden da ein bisschen geändert und die unterscheiden sich eigentlich dadurch, dass es keine festen Vorschriften gibt für diese Basislaser, diese billigen Plasteteile. Die haben in der Regel kein Display, kein Pad, wo man also eine kleine Tastatur oder so nichts, sondern die sind einfach nur so billige Plasteteile. So sind auch die, die wir getestet haben. Und die Komfortleser, die haben vorgeschrieben, dass sie auch ein Pinpad haben. Manche haben auch ein Display, also Display ist optional. Und bei den, nee, da sind die in der Mitte, also Standardleser. Und die Komfortleser, die früher Klasse 3 bezeichnet wurden, die müssen halt ein Pinpad haben und Display und die sind halt für die sogenannte elektronische Signatur, die qualifiziert ist, also rechtsgültig, dann vorgesehen. Leider, leider ist es derzeit so, dass kein einziges Komfortgerät und Standardgerät, sondern ausschließlich Basislaser zertifiziert sind.
Zertifiziert heißt?
Na, da hat BSI da sozusagen seinen Daumen nach oben gemacht.
Also im Zusammenhang mit dem EPA dürfen nur Klasse 1 Geräte benutzt werden?
Na, es sind einfach noch keine anderen zertifizierte.
Aber wir haben ja die Wahl.
Ja, wir haben ja die Wahl.
Was ist die Kritik an diesen, also was ist da unsicher als bei den anderen?
Na, das macht es halt einfacher. Das Abschnorchen wird vereinfacht, da man ja gezwungen ist, auf der Tastatur des Rechners diese PIN einzugeben.
Es ist immer auch ein Unterschied. Also die Leute behaupten immer, wir würden sagen, die seien unsicher oder so. Die wären unsicher, wenn man die unsicher verwendet. Man muss sich einfach im Klaren darüber sein, dass man höchstens die Hürden erhöht, indem man irgendwie als sicherer geltendes Lesegerät verwendet. Also wenn wir diese Basisgeräte nehmen, die keinen Pinpad haben und keinen Display, dann sind die Hürden sehr niedrig, denn dann wird z.B. auch die Pinden über den PC eingegeben, wo wir ja vorhin schon mal festgehalten haben, der ist ja eigentlich total unsicher. Da kann man sich eigentlich kaum schützen, also gerade eben gegen unbekannte Angriffe. Das ist also totaler Quatsch.
Und das heißt, wenn ich sozusagen so ein Klasse-2-Gerät habe, dann gebe ich meine Pinden ja über dieses Gerät ein und nicht über meinen infizierten Rechner?
Genau, dann kann man hoffen, dass dieses Lesegerät nicht infiziert ist.
Entschuldigung, bitte was?
Ja, ich mache mal, es läuft auf so einem Gerät. Das ist irgendwie ein kleiner Controller und ein bisschen Software und wer stellt sich dann hin und sagt, dass diese Dinger jetzt auch hundertprozentig sicher sind. Ich kann so ein Ding vielleicht auch manipulieren.
Es gab sogar schon einen Fall, der bekannt geworden ist, dass nämlich ein Klasse-3-Lesegerät der Firma Kubil gehackt wurde. Ja, es gibt übrigens einen Unterschied. Also die alten Klasse-3 sind nicht dieselben Leser wie diese Komfort-Leser, denn dieses sogenannte Terminate-Zertifikat gab es früher nicht. Also die haben schon neue Klassen festgelegt, das ist nur so ungefähr das Gleiche. Aber das wird den normalen Benutzer eh nicht interessieren. Also das würde meine Mama nur auch nicht erklären wollen, wie sich die...
Den Basislaser gibt es umsonst.
Also der kostet so 15, 20 Euro, aber die Bundesregierung hat für 25 Millionen Euro schonmal eine Million angeschafft. Ja, die werden zum Beispiel an die Banken irgendwie verschenkt. Also diejenigen, die die Nüste anbieten wollen, zum Beispiel eine Versicherung oder so, die haben natürlich ein Interesse, das sollte doch benutzen. Überhaupt ist natürlich ein großes Interesse, dass die Bürger das annehmen, da wenn es keiner benutzt, dann haben wir diese ganzen Millionen alle umsonst ausgegeben. Insofern gibt es natürlich so eine Art Incentivierung.
Auch eine Frage, die im Wiki steht, wer verdient denn jetzt eigentlich an diesem neuen Zeug?
Naja, zunächst natürlich erstmal die Leute, die die Lesegräte herstellen, weil jeder, der einen Personalausweis dann so benutzen möchte, braucht ja einen Lesegräte. Aber hier hängt natürlich schon eine fette Industrieförderung dran. Auch die Bundesdruckerei, die ja auch ziemliche Probleme hatte so in letzter Zeit, was ihre Solvenz betrifft. Klar, also hier verdienen eine ganze Menge Leute dran. Es geht natürlich auch um die Chip-Industrie, also hier ist schon eine gute Wirtschaftsförderung am Laufen. Es ist auch nicht so, dass das geheim gehalten wird. Das wird tatsächlich auch als Industrieförderungsprojekt dargestellt. Das ist nicht etwa so, dass das eine Verschwörungstheorie ist. Wir müssen noch ein paar Grüße ausrichten. Wir haben hier so ein paar Langzeit-Meckere. Einer von denen ist Detlef Borchers.
Der hat einen schönen Tweet geschrieben zur Sendung, hab ich gerade gelesen.
Wir müssen ihn mal grüßen und wollen ihn fragen, ob die Schnittchen in der Bundesdruckerei gut geschmeckt haben. Also er wirft uns hier vor, dass wir diese Gleichsetzung zwischen der SuisseID und dem elektronischen Personalausweis nicht vornehmen dürfen, dass es vollkommen unterschiedlich sei. Das tun wir gar nicht. Das tun wir gar nicht. Sondern wir haben nur die sogenannten High-Level-Angriffe halt auf beides, weil sie konzeptuell ähnlich sind, durchführen können. Und deshalb haben wir das überhaupt verglichen. Wir sehen halt diese Angriffe für sehr viele dieser Identitätskarten als gültige Angriffswege. Deswegen finden wir die Kritik eigentlich auch wenig fundiert. Natürlich gibt es da große Unterschiede. Wir haben die auch dargestellt. Aber am Ende konnten wir mit genau den gleichen Angriffstour hier vorgehen. Das ist einfach mal ein Fakt. Also nun ja.
Wenn ihr andere Kritik an der Kritik habt, könnt ihr gerne anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110. So hat es zum Beispiel auch der Max getan. Hallo Max. Du bist jetzt aber nicht der andere Max, der dein Ausweis untersucht hat, oder?
Okay, den würden wir erkennen, der hat nämlich so einen Schweizer Dialekt.
Verstehe, verstehe. Was ist deine Frage zum EPA?
Meine Frage zum EPA ist folgende, und zwar wurde da am Anfang schon mal was gesagt, darauf beziehe ich mich jetzt auch, dass der Ausweis nicht in physikalischer Form vorliegen muss, um ihn auszulesen, beziehungsweise um Betrügereien vorzunehmen. Das würde ich ganz gerne mal genauer wissen, weil an anderer Stelle wird ja genau das Gegenteil behauptet.
Du benutzt schon den Begriff Auslesen, das ist schon mal sehr schwammig, also wir haben nie von Chip Auslesen gesprochen oder von Chip Knacken. Das ist jetzt, ich will dich damit jetzt gar nicht anpaulen, dass das im Endeffekt richtet sich diese Kritik jetzt irgendwie an all diese ganzen Medien und Leute, die jetzt meinen, ihren Arsch retten zu müssen und eben zu sagen, ihr habt ihn doch gar nicht geknackt und ihr könnt ihn gar nicht auslesen. Das haben wir nie behauptet. Wir haben uns nie hingestellt und gesagt, wir können diesen Chip Remote auslesen oder kopieren oder sonst was. Das war überhaupt gar nicht das Ziel unserer Übung.
Ich glaube, es geht max um die Frage, muss man diesen Ausweis irgendwie physisch haben oder nicht?
Und das kann man klar beantworten mit Nein.
Die Antwort ist wirklich klar.
Die Antwort ist Nein. Also ganz einfach, wir wollen den Chip, wenn wir ihn jetzt nicht auslesen, wir wollen im Endeffekt zum Beispiel, also einfaches Beispiel, wir haben eine Banking-Session und machen da eine Überweisung, also irgendeine Transaktion und wir möchten irgendwie diese Transaktion modifizieren, beeinflussen. Aber in irgendeiner Art und Weise, dann brauchen wir keinen Zugriff auf dieses Gerät. Das heißt, es reicht eine Netzwerkverbindung, das ist das, was wir demonstriert haben und dokumentiert haben. Und auch um eine digitale Signatur durchzuführen, also wir haben das bei der SuisseID demonstrieren können, weil wir da halt digital signieren konnten, das sind auch Verfahren, die dann für eine rechtskräftige Unterschrift da verwendet werden können. Da sind wir in der Lage gewesen, remote, also über einen entfernten PC, über das Netzwerk eine digitale Signatur durchzuführen.
Bei der Pin-Änderung von den Auslösen ist das dasselbe.
Genau.
Also wir haben den Pin an einem Ausweis geändert, der an einem ganz anderen Gerät steckte. Wir haben also wirklich tatsächlich damit auch gezeigt, dass man nicht physisch auf diese Karte zugreifen muss, sondern einfach nur den Rechner übernimmt, wo die Karte dran steckt.
Da kommen wir vielleicht direkt zum nächsten Punkt. Da gab es nämlich eine Kritik, aber wenn die den Pin ändern, was haben die denn davon? Wer würde denn so etwas tun? Das merkt doch der Anwender, weil dann geht ja die Pin gar nicht mehr. Was ist denn das für ein Angriff?
Ja, in der Tat. Was ist denn das für ein Angriff? Also ich meine, okay, das ist lustig irgendwie, ich kann dann lachen, weil im Lebenszimmer mein Kumpel seinen EPA nicht mehr verwenden kann, aber ist ja tatsächlich so ein Angriff, wo man so denkt, okay, Schabernagrunne?
Nehmen wir einfach mal an, dass wir irgendwie das Ganze automatisieren können. Das ist ja technisch durchaus machbar. Ja, wir machen das automatisch. Wir nehmen uns irgendeinen aktuellen PDF oder Adobe Flash Exploit, den noch keiner kennt und den kein Virenscanner kennt. Den wir gerade gefunden haben. Den haben wir gerade gefunden. Und dann jagen wir alle Deutschen zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt über irgendeinen Server, wo die auch garantiert rübergehen und dann infizieren wir diese ganzen PC.
Magst du da hier?
Also der Punkt ist hier schon, dass 40 Prozent aller PCs durch diesen Trojaner vielleicht infiziert werden. Und dann ändern wir von 40 Prozent aller Deutschen vielleicht den PIN von dem Pass oder Personals. Die Nile of Service? Ist das eine Option? Ich meine, was machen wohl die Meldeämter denn? Und was machen die Leute? Ich meine, die müssen dann eventuell alle zum Meldeamt rennen und sich einen neuen Perso ausstellen lassen und die müssen dafür bezahlen.
Oder sie rufen alle bei der Sperrhotline an.
Das könnte auch wirtschaftlich, na, wirtschaftliches Interesse.
Aber das ist ja immer eine interessante Frage, also es gibt eine Sperrhotline, das heißt, ich kann sozusagen meinen Ausweis irgendwie, was bedeutet das, den sperren lassen? Der kann dann nicht mehr in der Phone-Teile werden.
Na, wenn man zum Beispiel, das geht ja für ganz normale Fälle, die jetzt nichts irgendwie mit Angriffen per Computer zu tun haben, wenn ich also dem Verlierer etwa oder mir wird meine Börse geklaut, dann gibt es natürlich eine Sperrhotline, so wie das heute natürlich auch gibt. Es gibt ja eine Hotline in diesem Sinne, aber es gibt dann eine Hotline, wo man anrufen kann und sagen kann, ich habe meinen Chip und meinen Ausweis verloren. Und dann ist es natürlich so, dass man den Diensteanbietern zur Kenntnis geben muss. Deswegen gibt es heute diese Hotline. Denn alle, die diese Ausweise benutzen wollen, im Geschäft zu erkehren, müssen natürlich davon an Kenntnis gesetzt werden. Das wird sicherlich ein, zwei Mal am Tag passieren, dass die Datenbanken updaten, welche Personalausweise geklaut sind. Deswegen gibt es jetzt eine Sperrhotline. Wenn man natürlich den Ausweis wieder benutzen möchte, den ein Fremder ja quasi ge-owned hat, indem er die PIN einfach geändert hat, dann muss man zurück aufs Meldeamt. Also das kostet, glaube ich, 5 Euro extra Gebühr. Ich habe die Gebühren jetzt nicht so im Kopf, aber man muss dann eine Gebühr zahlen, auch wenn man es vergisst.
Und warte, die ich bezahle? Ich muss bezahlen, wenn jemand anders meine PIN ändert.
Was ist das Problem damit? Weil hast du nicht gelesen, da steht, der BSI sagt, dein Rechner muss sicher sein. Dein Problem, dein Geld.
Und du unterstützt die Wirtschaft damit.
Ja, ne, dann natürlich gerne. Wir waren bei 150 Euro, 5 Euro für PIN ändern, na gut, da kommt ein bisschen was zusammen.
Ne, ich glaube, ich bin mir bei den 5 Euro nicht sicher, ich glaube, das waren 5 Euro. Es gibt da einige Zusatzgebühren, weil natürlich zum Beispiel aus dem Bereich von den C-Karten bei Banken schon bekannt ist, dass einfach ein gewisser Anteil der Bevölkerung immer wieder seinen PIN vergisst. Das sind natürlich auch Kosten, die entstehen. Das heißt, das kann man vorher ungefähr kalkulieren, wie viel Prozent der Bevölkerung vergessen einfach diese PIN. Das ist ja übrigens auch nicht nur eine PIN. Man muss sich da mehrere PIN... Was? Die kann man sich doch aufschreiben.
Was ist denn die Ausweisung?
Es gibt sogar eine dritte PIN, also man muss sich zwei PIN merken, wenn man auch die Signatur benutzen möchte. Aber es gibt sogar eine dritte PIN, die ist für den hoheitlichen Bereich, die ist aufgedruckt auf dem Ausweis. Wenn man natürlich gegenüber den Polizisten nicht sagen kann, ich sag dir die PIN nicht, deswegen ist die dritte PIN aufgedruckt. Wenn also die Katze, zum Beispiel, naja, da gibt es jetzt viele Modelle, die man sich überlegen könnte, da so eine Ziffer wegkratzt, ist natürlich ein großes Problem. Ihr wisst schon, diese Katzen, ihr kennt das doch, oder?
Ja, ich hab auch ganz viele dieser Katzen zu Hause.
Okay, aber mit der PIN kann man dann sozusagen nur diese hoheitlichen Merkmale auslesen, die sind einfach nur die Dinge, die auf dem Ausweis stehen, plus die Biometrie.
Na ja, richtig, aber natürlich, also jetzt zum Beispiel die Fingerabdrücke sind ja, wenn man die freilich abgibt, die sind ja nicht auf dem Dokument aufgedruckt, also nur auf dem Chip.
Aber sozusagen, da kann man jetzt irgendwie nicht, mit dieser aufgedruckten PIN kann dann nichts irgendwie signiert werden oder sowas, die sind wirklich nur für diese Daten da.
Ja, das ist nur der hoheitliche Bereich, also die Daten, die auch sonst nur von hoheitlichen Stellen abgerufen werden können.
Okay, damit kann man höchsten Polizisten ärgern, wenn die Katze über meinen Ausweis gelaufen ist.
Also falls das passiert.
Also kann man damit ja sicherstellen, dass man wirklich annimmt, dass jemand, der auf diese Daten zugreifen will, diesen Ausweis tatsächlich in der Hand halten muss.
Man braucht die PIN, die aufgedruckt ist, auch für die Signatur, man kann sich also selber an den Fuß schießen, für die Signatur braucht man auch die PIN, die aufgedruckt ist. Aber Signatur wird wahrscheinlich sowieso niemand haben wollen, also wir haben ja schon früher gelernt, elektronische Signaturen werden ja schon länger angeboten, dass das eigentlich niemand haben will.
Da wollen wir nachher auch noch mal technisch ein bisschen ins Detail gehen.
Können wir eigentlich gleich machen, oder?
Erstmal den Max fragen. Du weißt da so ein bisschen.
Oh, war ich Max? Entschuldigung.
Ich hätte vielleicht darauf aufbauen nochmal eine Frage und zwar, wenn eventuell der Personalausweis in der Zukunft die Chance bedient, dass man auch Online-Transaktionen, also Online-Danking damit macht. Bis dato ist es ja so, dass ja viele Millionen Deutsche das Online-Danking wahrnehmen und momentan ist es ja so, dass es da eigentlich ja nur ein bisschen geht. Also ich habe ja meine Tanne zu Hause und mache dann eine Online-Transaktion, aber wenn ich dann das eventuell durch den Personalausweis dann auch machen kann, habe ich ja dann diesen Ausweis und da nochmal zurückzukommen auf die Frage von vorhin in physischer Form bei mir.
Ja, das ist auch das, was die Hersteller natürlich behaupten. Aber wenn du dieses Device, wo dein Crypto-Key da drauf ist, wo du also physikalisch sicherstellen musst, also dass du dieses Ding da hast und in deinen USB-Bus reinsteckst, dass das irgendwie so ein Faktor ist, den du besitzen musst, um so eine Banking-Transaktion zu authentifizieren oder autorisieren, dann, ja, das ist einfach, du steckst das Ding in deinen Computer und dein Computer macht dann irgendwas damit. Das ist also im Endeffekt etwas, was wir bei dieser SuisseID-Technik da zeigen konnten, dass diese Transaktion zwar durchgeführt wird, aber ich zum Beispiel bei einem Man in the Browser Angriff sehr wohl einfach noch Daten manipulieren kann, weil es spielt überhaupt gar keine Rolle, ob diese Smartcard jetzt da ist oder nicht. Man kann sich dagegen effektiver wehren, wenn man einfach noch einen weiteren sicheren Kommunikationskanal hat, zum Beispiel eben so eine TAN-Liste, iTAN-Liste oder imTAN. Das sind eben so mobile TAN-Volumen, dann noch mal eine TAN, die dann dynamisch erzeugt wird und über dein Mobiltelefon verschickt wird, die dann gebunden ist an dieser eine Transaktion. Das erhöht natürlich die Sicherheit enorm, dadurch dass du noch einen weiteren Kommunikationskanal hast. Diese Sicherheit ist auch wieder obsolet, wenn du deine Banking-Session über dein Mobiltelefon abwickelst oder deine SMS auf deinem PC über ein GSM oder Modem erhältst. Die Smartcard bietet da keinen wirklichen Vorteil, kann man nicht so sagen.
Wo wir schon bei den Smartcard sind, ich würde gerne noch etwas nachtragen. Wir haben ja schon gesagt, was das für ein Chip in der SuisseID ist. Ich habe noch mal nachgeguckt, wie die in dem elektronischen Personalausweis sind. Das ist ein NXP Smart MX oder ein Siemens SLE 70. SLE 78. Also wer den Chip wissen will, ich wollte nur mal nachtragen. Ich hatte die vorhin einfach nicht im Kopf weg, wüsste nur, dass die eine NXP ist. Also wer noch mal nachgucken will, ist der Smart MX von der NXP.
Wer den schon mal sozusagen aufbauen will.
Oder der Siemens SLE 78. Es war schon interessant, welcher Chip das wird. Das war auch schon eine Weile quasi für uns eine Frage. Also klar, weil bei uns auch einfach jetzt ein paar Leute sind, die sich sehr intensiv mit dem Aufschleifen und Abbrezen von den Chips befasst haben. Und weil wir mittlerweile auch einen ganz guten Prozess haben, die Bilder, die man daraus generiert, einfach sich ein bisschen automatisiert anzusehen.
Ich möchte noch mal ganz kurz abschließend vielleicht zu der Frage noch was sagen. Wir sind gerade abgewichen. Aber wenn man zum Beispiel auch im Besitz der PIN ist, was wir ja auch demonstriert haben, dann kann man das Ding natürlich auch remote übernehmen und dann damit beliebig Transaktionen durchführen. Also zumindest was die derzeitigen Lösungen angeht, die auf Smartcard basieren. Also wenn ich die PIN besitze und Zugriff auf diese Smartcard habe und ich muss Zugriff nicht lokal haben, das heißt ich kann auch Remote-Zugriff haben. Das ist das, was wir gezeigt haben. Wir haben nichts weiter getan als dieses ganze USB-Device einmal übers Netzwerk zu schieben. Das heißt, auf der Angreiferseite hatte ich Zugriff auf dieses USB-Device, wie als wenn das selber in dem Angreifer-PC drin steckt.
Man wartet halt einen Moment länger, als man üblicherweise kennt.
Das braucht natürlich, aber das ist ein Angreifer.
Das ist schon ein bisschen unbequem, oder?
Aber es funktioniert trotzdem nur so lange, wie verdient das Geld. Wie der Ausweis da auf dem Gerät liegt. Das muss schon sein.
Ja, der muss auf dem Gerät liegen. Man kann ihn ein Stück weg bewegen. Das ist ja eine kontaktlose Technologie, also Funk, aber nicht allzu weit.
Aber wir reden ja auch über die SuisseID und die ist nicht kontaktlos. Und das ist nur so ein Dover-USB-Dongel. Und jetzt muss man sich einfach mal vorstellen, dass der PC in der Regel unter dem Schreibtisch steht und die Leute unter den Schreibtisch krabbeln müssen, um diesen Stick da reinzustecken. Das ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass in solchen Fällen, innerhalb von Sekunden, wo dieser Stick nicht benutzt wird, dann auch rausgezogen wird, damit auch ganz sicher nichts mehr passieren kann.
Es ist schon so, dass in dem White Paper BSI sagt, man möge ihn doch unternehmen, wenn man ihn nicht benutzt. Das ist natürlich auch entlarvend, diese Aussage.
Sie nehmen tatsächlich an, dass eine Angreifersoftware länger als ein paar Sekunden braucht, um dieses Ding zu hijacken oder damit irgendwelche bösen Dinge zu tun. Die Computer sind ganz schön schnell und die Software, die ein Angreifer schreibt, wird auch schnell abgearbeitet. Ich denke, das ist kein Argument, das dauerhaft Bestand haben wird. Ich denke, das sollte ihrem klar sein.
Okay, Max, sind deine Fragen mittlerweile alle beantwortet? Dann viel Spaß mit deinem neuen Personalausweis. So, Thorsten hat jetzt gerade noch etwas erwähnt, was ich zum ersten Mal im Zusammenhang hier gehört habe. Man in the middle kenne ich. Das ist sozusagen, man hängt sich in eine Kommunikationsleitung und tauscht beiden Seiten vor. Man sei der jeweils andere und der richtige und der gute. Jetzt hast du gerade man in the browser gesagt.
Was ist das? Hört sich an wie ein tolles Buzzword aus irgendeiner Media Agentur.
Ich finde, es hört sich an wie ein Flash Spiel. Ist das gut?
Ja, wenn man wie ich viel im Browser arbeitet. Was ist man in the browser? Im Endeffekt haben wir hier die Möglichkeit, Browser beliebig zu erweitern. Das sind dann irgendwie XPIs, das sind Browser-Erweiterungen. Das sind so kleine Module, die kann man sich in den Firefox reinflanschen.
Also grundsätzlich ist man in the browser eine Art und Weise, Rechner anzugreifen. Das habe ich richtig verstanden.
Eine Methode.
Und was du jetzt gesagt hast, diese Erweiterung für Browser ist ja erstmal das, was man kennt. Also was was Gutes ist, ein Plugin, was zusätzliche Funktionalität, wenn man Browser macht. Also dafür gedacht, mit dem Leben einfacher zu machen.
Ja, das ist halt wie ein Programm. Du hast ja ein PC mit einem Betriebssystem drauf. Dann hast du ein PC mit einem Betriebssystem drauf, aber du kannst damit nichts tun, außer ein PC mit einem Betriebssystem zu bieten.
Der Browser kann immerhin browsen, aber gut.
So diese Browser, die haben halt einfach diese Möglichkeit, Module zu installieren, genauso wie du auf deinem PC die Möglichkeit hast, Programme zu installieren. Diese Module im Browser, dass es eben irgendwie mehr oder weniger standardisiert ist, da gibt es halt eine Programmierschnittstelle. Und wenn man sich nach dieser Programmierschnittstelle richtet, kann man da einfach so beliebige Extra-Funktionalitäten implementieren. Es gibt ziemlich viele, die sind sehr sinnvoll. Es gibt halt irgendwie Spielereien. Aber es gibt auch Schadsoftware. Was hindert mich daran, eine Schadsoftware zu basteln, die ich dann im Browser installiere und nicht auf dem Betriebssystem. Also dieses XPI zum Beispiel, das ist dann irgendwie ein Haufen JavaScript. Und ich benutze dann auch ganz reguläre und dokumentierte ARPs, also Programmierschnittstellen. Und naja, nun kann man sich ja mal überlegen, wie wahrscheinlich das ist, dass das von einer Virenssoftware, Anti-Virenssoftware erkannt wird als Schadsoftware.
Aber man hatte noch einen Firewall, sagt das BLSI.
Ja, aber man hat einen Firewall-Block natürlich auch alles, was HTTP ist.
Entschuldigung. Aber wir haben halt schon, also wir mussten schon teilweise schmunzeln über die Hinweise.
Warte, warte, warte. Also zu sagen, es gibt diese Erweiterung für den Browser und da kann man sozusagen, kann man sagen, ihr, kann man auch welche programmieren, die sind sozusagen schadhaft. Also sie spielen dann irgendwas aus, das müssen wir gleich nochmal klären. Aber die kommen jetzt nicht einfach so durchzaubert in den Browser. Also normalerweise werden die Erweiterungen ja von mir installiert. Das heißt, ich müsste den Tonnen noch eine weitere Sicherheitslücke ausnutzen, um das Ding jemand unterzuschieben oder?
Entweder das, also so eine Sicherheitslücke muss natürlich bekannt sein, wenn man die ausnutzen möchte, zumindest dem Angreifer. Die muss ja nicht publik sein, die muss ja nicht öffentlich bekannt sein. Aber ich meine, das einfachste ist, jemandem so ein Ding unterzujubeln. Gerade diese Browser Security ist halt vielleicht manchmal auch nicht ganz so fortgeschritten wie beim Betriebssystem, wo es dann viel mehr Warnmeldungen gibt und so weiter. Aber wenn man einfach sagt, okay, ich nerfe den Benutzer so lange mit irgendwelchen Dialogfeldern, bis er irgendwann Ja klickt, dann hat man es auch. Und dann ist man da irgendwie in diesem Browser drin, kann sich da als XPI registrieren und kann dann meinetwegen einfach im einfachsten Fall ja suchen, ersetzen. Also ich meine, im Endeffekt kann ich auch, ja, ich kann irgendwie gucken, wenn mein Opfer so eine Bankingseite aufruft, dann habe ich die URL, dann sehe ich, ok, jetzt führt er eine Transaktion durch und dann tausche ich ja einfach mal den Betrag und oder die Kontonummer aus und hoffe einfach, dass er das nicht checkt, wenn er dann irgendwie auch noch die Transaktion bestätigen muss.
Also du willst mir gerade sagen, egal wie gut das Lesegerät und die Karte ist, wenn du der Mann im Browser bist, das ist eigentlich egal.
Ja, das hat auch den Vorteil im Gegensatz zu einer Mann in the Middle Attacke, die man halt so netzwerkbasiert kennt, es gibt halt auch keine Zertifikatswarnungen vom Browser.
Naja, gut, also Zertifikatswarnungen sind aber natürlich in der Praxis eigentlich auch nicht relevant.
Nee, aber ich meine, so ein Man in the Browser ist tatsächlich irgendwie so ein Angriffspunkt, wo ich mir sage, das wird ich nicht checken. Weil wie auch, ich werde ja nicht gewarnt. Ich rufe irgendwie meine Webseite auf, wo ich gewohnt bin, dass das Zertifikat immer gleich ist, weil ich das einfach mal auch mal den Fingerprint vielleicht verifiziert habe, irgendwie meine Bank oder was auch immer. Und wenn ich im Browser diese Chartsoftware habe, dann agiert die zwischen dem Bildschirm, also das, was der User liest, und bis zu dem Punkt, wo dann angefangen wird, diese Daten auch zu verschlüsseln und auch zu verifizieren, ob der Server tatsächlich der Server ist. Also ich werde niemals darauf aufmerksam gemacht, dass da noch jemand dazwischen sitzt, weil es passiert im Browser.
Das heißt aber auch, dass eigentlich die Angriffe, die wir hier so demonstriert haben jetzt, das gilt in gleicher Weise für die SuisseID wie auch für den Ausweis, dass sie natürlich auch noch stark erweitert werden können, weil diese Männchen so Browser-Angriffe natürlich auch nochmal eine Klasse von Angriffen sind. Und wenn der Mann jetzt Thorsten so sagt, naja, da würde ich mich jetzt mal selber nicht gegen werden können, würde vielleicht sogar mir nicht auffallen, würde mich sehr intensiv mit der Sicherheit meines Rechners befassen. Dann muss man vielleicht auch nochmal nachdenken, dass es hier eben gerade nicht um diese Tech-Community gibt, sondern jeder stellt sich jetzt nochmal kurz seine Mutter oder seinen Onkel vor, der irgendwie auch mit diesem Ding umgehen will. Und da finde ich schon, dass man die ganze Zertifikatssache auch ruhig nochmal betrachten kann.
Ja, das Tolle ist halt, dass wir sie eigentlich gar nicht betrachten müssen, denn wir brauchen gar nicht mit diesem Umstand kämpfen eigentlich. Wir sind überhaupt gar nicht darauf angewiesen, dass ein Benutzer auf unser Zertifikat reinfällt. Er wird es gar nicht merken. Für ihn wird ein valides Zertifikat angezeigt von der Gegenstelle. Und das ist einfach das Tolle daran. Also es ist einfach mal extrem schwer zu bemerken und das ist so.
Und wenn wir jetzt sozusagen eigentlich schon so viele von den verschiedenen Wegen, die A schon gezeigt wurden und B, die aber auch möglich sind, die man durchführen kann, was ist eigentlich die Folge? Also was folgt als Forderung daraus? Also der eine ist natürlich, dass wir erwarten, dass zumindest auf die wichtigsten dieser Sicherheitsprobleme hingewiesen wird bei der Ausgabe. Das finde ich ist einfach eine Forderung, die man an den Staat, der diese gesetzlich vorschreibt, geben muss. Das gilt aber in gleicher Weise aus meiner Sicht für die SuisseID, wo die Unternehmen, die die verschicken, auf sowas hinweisen müssen. Aber wahrscheinlich wird es in der Schweiz sowieso nochmal ein paar signifikantere Folgen geben, als jetzt in Deutschland für den chronischen Personalausweis. Aber die zweite Forderung ist aus meiner Sicht auch, dass bestimmte Arten von Kombinationen, etwa diese billigen Lesegeräte, mit dem Ausweis nicht erlaubt werden sollten. Das ist aus meiner Sicht vollkommen klar. Das ist ein Einfallstor, was man den Leuten unterjubelt. Vor allen Dingen die Leute, die sich nicht mit der Sicherheit ihrer Computer beschäftigen.
Eine berechtigte Kritik an diesen ganzen Verfahren, die wir hier gezeigt haben, ist ja auch gewesen, dass man, man bringt immer Vergleiche. Zum Beispiel sagt man ja auch, man geht ja auch das Risiko ein, überfahren zu werden, wenn man das Haus verlässt und auf die Straße geht und über die Straße läuft. Dann, klar, setzt man sich dann einen gewissen Risiko aus, dass man überfallen wird, dass man überfahren wird und so weiter. Aber wir haben hier bereits in der Grundschule so was wie eine Verkehrserziehung. Das heißt, man wird darauf vorbereitet, man wird als Kind schon darauf sensibilisiert, dass man im Verkehr einfach, im Straßenverkehr vorsichtig sein muss. Und das geschieht hier in Bezug auf diese vermeintliche Erhöhung des Sicherheitsniveaus für so Online-Bezahlverfahren und Authentifizierungsverfahren. Nicht ganz im Gegenteil. Es wird eher suggeriert, dass jetzt alles sicher ist und man eigentlich überhaupt gar nichts mehr machen muss. Der Anwender wägt sich in Sicherheit und das ist wahrscheinlich irgendwie das Fatale an dem gesamten Konzept.
Also da sind wir irgendwie bei der Kompetenz, wo man auch eigentlich immer bei diesem Thema landet. Die andere Frage, bei der man auch immer landet, ist, wenn man so eine Horrorszenarien entwirft, ist sozusagen, wer will das denn eigentlich? Wer interessiert sich denn eigentlich dafür, was ich jetzt mit meinem Ehepaar anstelle? Meine Güte, vielleicht passiert es irgendwann, aber relativ wahrscheinlich auch nicht. Das müssen wir gleich auf jeden Fall auch nochmal klären. Bevor wir das machen, machen wir aber das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Und dann geht es hier weiter mit dem Chaosradio.
Superradio 3000, wir spielen die größten Super-Mega-Hits aller Zeiten mit der meisten Abwechslung und den besten von heute im Super-Mega-Mix. Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich spiele der Jupp Nippenbräusch von Nippenbräusch Kleiderbügel International Unlimited. Ich habe Millionen mit Kleiderbügel gemacht.
Interessant.
Und jetzt steige ich ganz groß in die Politik ein. Und deswegen werde ich eure Sender-Klitscherer kaufen.
Ich kaufe die Monitorin, ich kaufe die Musiker, ich kaufe die Techniker, der ganze Puff. Und dann kaufe ich mir noch ein paar Radiosender, ohne ein paar Fernsehsender, ohne ein paar Zeitungen dazu. Und alle müssen sich gut über mich berichten.
Interessant.
Und dann lasse ich mich wählen. Jetzt spielt keine Rolle.
Verstehe, da verbinde ich Sie gerne mal eben mit unserer Marketing-Abteilung.
Es muss auch Radio- und Fernsehsender geben, die von mächtigen Milliardären und Meinungsmachern unabhängig sind. Und die man nicht kaufen kann. Fritz?
Es ist ein öffentlich-rechtliches Radioprogramm.
Und abhängig sind wir auch. Aber nur von euch.
Fritz.
Powered bei eurer Rundfunkgebühren.
Und das hört man.
Um kurze halb zwölf.
Fritz-Info.
Nachrichten mit Kai et al.
Die Hochwasserlage in Südbrannenburg bleibt angespannt. Am Abend wurde das Krankenhaus von Esther Werder evakuiert. Vorher wurden 2500 Bewohner der Innenstadt in Sicherheit gebracht. Für den Fluss Schwarzer Elster gilt die höchste Alarmstufe 4. In 16 Schulen der Region fällt morgen die Schule aus. Auch die Nachbarstadt Bad Liebenwerder ist vom Hochwasser bedroht. Dort soll aber zunächst nicht evakuiert werden. Brandenburgs Ministerpräsident Platzek erwartet für morgen eine weitere Verschärfung der Hochwassersituation im Süden Brandenburgs. Bundeskanzlerin Merkel hat die Debatte um steigende Mieten neu angeheizt. In einem Zeitungsinterview sagte sie, dass Hauseigentümer künftig einen größeren Teil der Kosten für Wärmedämmung an die Mieter weitergeben dürfen. Der Deutsche Mieterbund reagierte empört. Es könne nicht sein, dass die energetische Sanierung auf dem Rücken der Mieter ausgetragen werde. Die Europäische Union will Verstöße gegen den Euro-Stabilitätspakt strenger bestrafen. Damit zieht die EU-Kommission Konsequenzen aus der Finanzkrise. Länder, die zu hohe Schulden machen, müssen dann schneller Geldbusen zahlen als bisher. Auch wenn Länder ihre Schulden zu langsam abbauen, müssen sie in Zukunft zahlen. Der amerikanische Regisseur Arthur Penn ist tot. Nur einen Tag nach seinem 88. Geburtstag ist er in New York gestorben. Penn wurde vor allem durch den Film Bonnie und Clyde über das legendäre Gangsterpärchen berühmt. Einen weiteren Erfolg feierte er mit dem kritischen Western Little Big Man. Bei der Berlinale vor drei Jahren wurde Penn mit dem Ehrenbären für sein Lebenswerk ausgezeichnet. In der Fußball-Champions League hat Schalke einen Sieg verbucht. Die Gelsenkirchener gewannen das Heimspiel gegen den portugiesischen Verein Benfica Lissabon mit 2 zu 0. Werder Bremen unterlag im Auswärtsspiel den Titelverteidiger Inter Mailand mit 0 zu 4. In Berlin und Brandenburg sind es aktuell Temperaturen zwischen 7 und 9 Grad. Die Nacht bleibt fast überall trocken und es bleibt auch vergleichsweise kühl bei Tiestärten zwischen 5 und nur einem Grad. Tagsüber lässt sich dann immer wieder die Sonne blicken. Es regnet nur selten und es bleibt vergleichsweise kühl mit Temperaturen zwischen 10 und 13 Grad. Ich habe eine Meldung hier nur aus Brandenburg, A13, Dresden Richtung Berlin zwischen Schönbrunn und Ruhland. Dort ist gesperrt, eine Umleitung ist beschildert. Ihr Grund ist die überflutete Fahrbahn dort. Ihr müsst dort auch mit Staus rechnen. A15 Übergang Forst Richtung Dreieck Spreewald zwischen Cottbus West und Fettschau. Dort liegen Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn. Drum vorsichtig fahren dort. A24 Hamburg Richtung Berlin zwischen Europien Süd und dem Dreieck Hafelland. Dort fährt ein Schwertransporter, den könnt ihr nicht überholen. Ohne letzte Meldung noch von der B169. Elsterwerder Richtung Cottbus zwischen der Kürzung Plesser und Lochheimer West. Auch dort macht das Hochwasser Probleme. Die Straße ist überspült. Das Ganze dauert noch die ganze Nacht. Dort gibt es auch eine Umleitung. War nicht eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Und neue Musik im www.faitz.de be-i-i.
Heute mit Chaosradio, mit Konstanze Kurz und Thorsten Schröder, der hat den EPA auseinander genommen und die SuisseID, das sind beides ähnliche Konzepte zur Online-Identifizierung.
Wir wollten dann nochmal sagen, was genau da eigentlich ähnlich ist.
Aber das haben wir euch schon zweimal geklärt.
Ja, aber offenbar haben noch nicht alle Hörer verstanden. Entschuldigung. Also der Punkt ist, dass das eher ein konzeptioneller Angriff ist, und dass beide Maler einfach durch Schadsoftware einfach an die Daten gelangt werden können. Die mögen physisch unterschiedlich aussehen. Und wer die mal sieht, also einer ist eine Plastikarte, der andere...
Das sind ja sogar andere Chips, die Technik dahinter ist eine andere. Ja, aber hallo, wir haben es gezeigt. Wir haben ein und denselben Angriff gegen beide Geräte gefahren und hatten damit Erfolg.
Exakt den...
Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, Leute. Es hat kein Hörer, der angerufen hat, bestrungen. Nein, was zur Hölle ist hier gerade los?
Na ja, du musst doch mal sehen, dass wir diesen Chat zur Sendung haben. Nur weil der Moderator bei diesem Chaosradio den nicht mitliest. Es ist schließlich unser vierter Kanal. Na ja, da müssen wir doch uns ein bisschen zu äußern.
Da ist also sozusagen das angeprangert worden, zum Wiederholmal oder wie?
Na ja, weil die so unterschiedlich aussehen, ist vielleicht irgendwie für manchen Hörern immer nicht ganz klar, wie ähnlich sie doch sind, wenn man ganz oben bei den Angriffen ansetzt. Und sich gar nicht weiter mit den Techniken im Einzelnen befasst, sondern sich einfach den Rechner, da wurde im USB eingesteckt, das krallt.
Okay, also man hat jetzt dreimal gesagt, SwissID und EPA sind nicht dasselbe, aber es sind ähnliche Konzepte, deswegen kann man sie auch sozusagen grob zusammen betrachten. Wenn ihr es immer nicht verstanden habt, dann könnt ihr gerne nochmal anrufen, 0331 77 97 21 0 auf weitere Chatbeschwerden. Zum Thema gehen wir jetzt nicht mehr ein.
Richtig.
So, und jetzt haben wir hier tatsächlich noch am Telefon den anderen Max, nämlich den Max, der mit Thorsten zusammen daran gearbeitet.
Hallo Max, grüezi.
Ich rufe an, weil ich noch einen wichtigen Input heute direkt jetzt während der Sendung sogar gelesen habe und zwar hatten wir uns ja die ganze Zeit während den Talks immer und auch während der Vorbereitung überlegt, Mann, das kann ja nicht sein, dass in der Schweiz das zulässig sein kann, dass ich ein JavaScript in einem PDF mitsignieren kann, obwohl es nicht dargestellt wird. Ich habe jetzt das gerade mal durchgelesen und da gibt es tatsächlich einen Punkt zur Nutzung der Signaturprüfung und da heißt es, einen Klarpunkt, die zur Überprüfung der Signatur verwendeten Daten entsprechen den Daten, die der Überprüferin oder dem Überprüfer angezeigt werden. Und ich meine, das ist eigentlich eindeutiger geht es nicht.
Da müssen wir natürlich mal ein bisschen erklären, weil wir sind jetzt nicht so sehr auf die Signatur eingegangen. Vielleicht willst du das mal selber machen?
Ja, ich kann gut zuhören, das ist gar kein Thema.
Vielleicht trennen wir das thematisch, wir haben ja auch noch…
Eine halbe Stunde, also 22 Minuten noch.
Also es ist ja ein Teil von den Angriffen gegen die SuisseID nicht gesendet worden. Dabei geht es zum Beispiel auch darum, dass wir mal schauen wollten, wenn man eine elektronische Signatur mit dieser SuisseID macht, inwieweit kann man da auch den Benutzer täuschen. Das heißt, ist ein PDF, so wie man es angezeigt bekommt, eigentlich das, was man auch elektronisch signiert. Und hier haben wir sehr konkret gezeigt, dass das nicht immer der Fall sein muss. Und darauf spielt Max jetzt gerade an. Denn die unterschiedlichen Applikationen, die PDFs darstellen, die sind halt bei diesem doch sehr umfangreichen Format nicht immer sehr gleich.
Das heißt, die PDF-Spezifikation umfasst mehrere tausend Seiten, wenn man sich auch alle Erweiterungen und so noch mit reinzieht. Und es gibt ziemlich viele PDF-Reader-Hersteller und die interpretieren diese Spezifikation jeweils unterschiedlich, sei es aus Faulheit oder einfach Unwissen. Und das ist ein Punkt, das haben Max und ich auch gezeigt und demonstriert. Wir haben vielleicht ein etwas unglückliches Beispiel gewählt für unsere Demo.
Was habt ihr denn da gemacht?
Na ja, wir haben einen MoFa-Kaufvertrag. Aber vielleicht können wir das einfach nochmal ändern. Wir sagen jetzt einfach mal, wir haben irgendwie…
Jetzt ist gerade der Punkt, wo es so ein bisschen anfängt, die Leute vom Radio zu vergessen, weil die wissen nicht, was ihr mit dem MoFa gemacht habt. Erzählt das kurz und dann machen wir es nochmal anders.
Also, wir haben ein PDF, also wir haben uns die Signatursoftware betrachtet und haben ja gesagt, okay, die ursprüngliche Idee ist ja, dass ich mit einer Signatur sicherstelle, dass ein Dokument nicht mehr verändert werden kann, bis es halt durch den Betrachter nochmal angeschaut wird und halt, wie nennen die das, die Überprüferin bzw. Überprüfer diesen Inhalt auch sehen kann. Das würde ja schon mal als Grundlage benötigen, dass es ein Dokument ist, welches zu Beginn schon nicht verändert dargestellt werden kann, also sprich, keine aktiven Inhalte haben muss. Und da war uns eigentlich schon offensichtlich, naja, PDF ist vielleicht nicht das geeignete Format, genauso wie es vielleicht Wördmarkus nicht unbedingt wären. Und dann hatten wir ganz eine einfache Idee, naja, was ist denn, wenn ich jetzt zwei überlagende Bilder habe und ich mache ganz einfach in einem PDF-Invent, on-page-open, height-picture-2 zum Beispiel. Und somit wird dann das zum Beispiel intakte Webmofa in unserem Beispiel gegen ein anderes ausgetauscht, sofern die Signatursoftware oder der Reader diese JavaScript-Language interpretiert. Und genau da driftet dann die Produkte auseinander, so war es konkret, dass die Signatursoftware JavaScript ignoriert hat, aber das Dokument signiert, also nicht irgendwie darauf hingewiesen oder das nur dargestellt. Und der Acrobat dann zum Beispiel als lesende Funktion hat das sehr wohl interpretiert und zeigt dann das andere Bild an. Dass die Signatur dann noch intakt blieb, das ist nur unter gewissen Umständen korrekt, also man kann das erkennen, dass das nicht der originale Zustand war. Aber der Punkt ist, dass wie gesagt diese Grundlage jetzt gesetzlich mittlerweile anscheinend auch klar ist, dass halt schon das Ursprungsdokument nicht so ist, wie es tatsächlich ist, denn es ist ein JavaScript drin und das wird halt nicht dargestellt. Also mir ist das nicht ersichtlich als Signierer, dass dieses Dokument noch irgendwelche aktive Inhalte hat. Das ist somit natürlich für diesen Gesetzesartikel eigentlich schon Grund genug. Also wenn ich das Dokument nicht alles mir zeigt, was es beinhaltet, ist natürlich die Rechtsgrundlage sehr fragwürdig.
Ok, ich komme jetzt noch aufs konkrete Beispiel zurück. Ihr habt also einen Kaufvertrag gefaked, quasi kann man sagen. Ich unterschreibe den mit meiner elektronischen Unterschrift, sehe darauf ein ganzes Mofa und wenn später irgendjemand anders sozusagen, der den Kaufvertrag begutachtet anguckt, dann sieht ihr da ein kaputtes Mofa und oder wie?
Genau, und die Signatur blieb in diesen Beispiel, wie gesagt, das kann man erkennen, aber das ging es mehr darum, dass es tatsächlich Unterschiede gibt in der Darstellung und das ist natürlich entgegen jeder Idee von einer Signatur mit Unveränderbarkeit.
Es hätte keinen Bestand, wenn da ein Richter oder ein Forensiker noch mal draufschaut, wenn es später zu einem Rechtschreib kommt. Das ist völlig richtig, aber deswegen möchte ich eigentlich gerne ein anderes Beispiel reinbringen. Zum Beispiel, ich nehme einen Arbeitnehmer, der bewirbt sich in einer Firma, wo er seit zehn Jahren arbeiten möchte, sein Wunscharbeitgeber und er schafft es endlich da reinzukommen und der macht mutwillig eben so einen Trick mit irgendeinem dynamischen Inhalt in so einem PDF und dann schließen die einen Arbeitsvertrag und irgendwann, nachdem auch der Arbeitnehmer das ganze Ding unterschrieben hat, stellt er fest, wieso habe ich jetzt nur noch die Hälfte Urlaub. Also einfach so ganz banale Sachen, wo der Arbeitgeber definitiv profitiert und auch mutwillig beschissen hat, da wird wohl nicht die erste Tätigkeit des neuen Arbeitnehmers sein, vor das Arbeitsgericht zu ziehen und diesen Vertrag anzufechten, weil er irgendwelche dynamischen Inhalte hat.
Es ist natürlich, das Format an sich ist natürlich eben sehr umfänglich.
Ja, das ist überhaupt nicht dafür geeignet. Also gar nicht.
Eigentlich müsste man sagen, dass die Signatur nur für so einfache Formate wie zum Beispiel Plain Text, also einfacher Text überhaupt ermöglicht werden sollte und diese dynamischen Inhalte, wo man ja die volle Mächtigkeit einer Programmiersprache hat, die sollten eigentlich so nicht drin sein.
Posttrip, das ist eine mächtige Programmiersprache im Endeffekt.
Ich bin sogar der Meinung, und das ist eigentlich, also wenn ich jetzt diesen Artikel hier wirklich durchgelesen habe, ist schon die Frage, ob solche Sachen wie Exif-Tags in Shape-Tags oder was auch immer, die mir nicht dargestellt werden in diesem Dokument, nur schon dem genüge tun. Also sprich, nur weil es jetzt kein PDF ist, heißt es ja nicht, dass es alle Daten, die existieren in dem Dokument, wie er auch wirklich dargestellt werden. Schon noch eine interessante Diskussion bei der ganzen Sache. Ich habe da mittlerweile auch gelernt, dass dieses Beispiel mit dem Moorverkauf, das hängt vielleicht an Enten und Unkanten, aber man darf nicht vergessen, wenn die Gegenstelle ein Automatismus ist, also nicht ein Mensch-Mensch-Bezugung, sondern irgendein E-Government-Dokument, welches automatisch verarbeitet wird. Wenn die Gegenstelle zum Beispiel jetzt diese Sachen rendern würde, auch wenn es sehr unwahrscheinlich ist, dann hat das unter Umstand zur Folge, dass die Maschine etwas anders interpretiert hat als tatsächlich in diesem Dokument stand.
Das ist sogar gar nicht mal so unwahrscheinlich, das habe ich auch im normalen Leben schon häufiger erlebt, das kommt halt vor.
Ja, sprich Dokument-Parser können auch nicht so gut sein, im Endeffekt. Das wollte ich nur noch mit einbringen, dass da tatsächlich noch eine kleine Änderung stattfand. Sprich, diesen Artikel gibt es, der ist einfach sehr offen gehalten, aber zeigt eigentlich, dass so eine Software, wie sie jetzt das handhabt, dem nicht genügend zählen kann, also definitiv nicht.
Okay, jetzt haben wir also sagen noch etwas weiteres gelernt, das ist nicht nur sagen, mit der Identifikation schwierig, sondern auch mit der Signatur kann man schön viel Unfug treiben. Scusi ist außerdem noch am Apparat und möchte noch ein paar Horror-Szenarien beisteuern.
Oh ja, Horror-Szenarien.
Guten Abend, ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen Rest, ich höre noch zu, ich glaube, dann ist die Leitung da auch wieder frei.
Wir können da doch zu viert und zu fünft hier. Diese Schweizer mögen uns nicht. Bleibt ruhig noch da, wenn ihr möchtet.
Hallo Max, hallo Konz, hallo T. Also mir sind noch ein paar lustige Sachen eingefallen von vorhin, dass mit der alte, mit der DOS-Attacke, gegen möglichst viele Ausweise, Pin-Nummern, Länder und so. Na ja, das kann man ja noch erweitern zu einem richtig lukrativen Cybercrime-Geschäft. Also ich meine, ein neuer EPA kostet 28 Euro und man muss zum Einwohnermeldeamt, wo selber, wenn der Angreifer die PIN für 15 Euro frei Haus per E-Mail schickt, dann wäre das ja vielleicht ein interessantes Geschäftsmodell.
Wir könnten alle reich werden.
Ja, aber guck mal, das ist doch ethisch fragwürdig, oder, Susi?
Das ist ethisch fragwürdig, aber ich meine, wir hatten es ja vorhin auch von Industrieförderung und zu befürchten steht halt einfach, dass das wirklich eine Industrieförderung ist. Allerdings wird der größte Nutzen nie so wohlmöglich die Cybercrime-Industrie.
Ja, das ist ja auch die Befürchtung, dass tatsächlich auch mal jemand in kurzer Zeit zeigen kann, dass man auf größerer Basis einfach schaffen kann. Das ist natürlich schon auch eine Gefahr aus meiner Sicht. Aber da ich eigentlich annehme, dass auch nur ein sehr kleiner Anteil der Bevölkerung überhaupt diese elektronische ID nehmen wird, also das wirklich benutzen wird, zumal am Anfang. Und noch viel schlimmer bei der Signatur ist es wahrscheinlich eher noch Zukunftsmusik.
Aber eins muss man auch noch mal ganz klar sagen, was diesen elektronischen Personalausweis angeht und all diese Möglichkeiten, die man hat als User und auch als Betrüger, auf beiden Seiten sinkt die Hemmschwelle damit irgendwie Unfug zu treiben. Also Angreifer brauchen eben nicht mehr hinter der Ecke nachzulauen, dass jemand vorbei rennt und ihn mit dem Knüppel über den Kopf hauen, um den Ausweis zu stehlen. Man kann übers Internet agieren, aus anderen Ländern, man kann seine Spuren verschleiern. Die Hemmschwelle sinkt. Ob man sich dabei dämlich anstellt und da ertappt wird oder nicht, ist mal dahingestellt.
Aber ich muss jetzt an dieser Stelle schon mal fragen, also alles was ihr sagt, was ihr jetzt sagen, über die Sicherheit dieses e-Pounder, CCC, die sagt, das könnte man ja theoretisch auch anwenden auf Online-Banking. Das sind jetzt ziemlich viele Horror-Szenarien, was aber andererseits bedeutet, eigentlich wäre doch heutzutage schon die totale Katastrophe möglich mit Online-Banking? Warum ist das nicht der Fall?
Na ja, wir hatten das vorhin schon mal kurz, als Thorsten erklärt hat, dass sich natürlich die Banken etwa mit diesem zweiten Weg, dass man eben auf seinem Mobiltelefon noch einen TAN hat oder schriftlich zu Hause einen TAN, auch schon Möglichkeiten überlegt haben, dem entgegenzusteuern.
Naja, aber da gibt es ja dann die Man in the Browser-Attacke, die auch das wieder aushebelt, dann können wir auch wieder sagen, okay.
Also man darf hier nicht, ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen Äpfel mit Birn vergleichen, weil man muss ja sehen, in einem Bankenumfeld existieren ja nicht nur die technischen Maßnahmen, sondern man hat ja typischerweise über Jahre hat man im Prinzip ja Profile angelegt, welche begünstigten sind populär, welche Zahlungsverhalten hat der Herr Moser zum Beispiel gegenüber seinen, wie hoch sind meine durchschnittlichen Beträge der Zahlung und so weiter. Und solche Fortdetection-Mechanismen sind ja ganz unabhängig von den Techniken. Und somit ist natürlich der Missbrauch. Ich würde jetzt auch mal einfach so behaupten, dass die meisten Detection von Phishing-Sachen eher auf dieses zurückzuführen, sondern auf technischen Mitteln. Und das ist natürlich ganz etwas anderes, wenn wir jetzt davon sprechen, dass Hinz & Kunz ein Web-Shop öffnet und das mit dieser Authentifizierung ja total sicher ist, weil die Applikation ist ja jetzt auch sicher, weil ja jetzt noch die Person identifiziert wird. Das ist nicht zu vergleichen.
Ich bin mir aber noch nicht ganz überzeugt, weil das, was du jetzt sagst, könnte man auch sagen, bei Banking halt nicht, dann aber meinetwegen bei Kreditkarten. Da kann ja auch jeder Web-Shop-Betreiber herkommen, ist das viel Geld, wo muss man da irgendwie bezahlen?
Na auch da ist eine Lösung gefunden worden, die noch gar nicht so lange her ist, nämlich die sogenannte, diese Sicherheitsnummer, die auf dem Dokument aufgedruckt ist, die man zusätzlich jetzt ja eingibt und die darf ja zum Beispiel der Anbieter auch nicht speichern. Aber auch hier ist es so, dass natürlich trotzdem eine Menge Schadensfälle bei den Banken auflaufen, weswegen sich bei den Banken jetzt ja auch was ändert. In der Zeit wird in Deutschland das sogenannte PIN-and-Chip-Verfahren, bei Visa heißt es Verified, bei Visa und bei Mastercard heißt es Secure Code, ausgeräutet, heißt wir erhalten jetzt gerade in Deutschland alle Kreditkarten, die einen Chip enthalten und man muss jetzt sich da auch eine PIN merken. Und hier ist ein sehr ähnlicher Effekt zu beobachten, wie wir beim Personalausweis haben, nämlich, dass die Problematik der Sicherheit mehr und mehr auf die Kunden ausgelagert wird und beim EPA auf die Bürger und bei der SuisseID eben diejenigen, die die kaufen. Das heißt, man muss sich selber darum kümmern, dass wie man nutzt, sicher ist. Denn auch bei diesen PIN und Chip-Perferen, bei den Kreditkarten gibt es Angriffswege, die sind auch bekannt, so wie es jetzt bekannte Angriffswege für die SuisseID und den Ausweis gibt. Aber die Defensline ist da irgendwie immer, ja, da müssen sich die User eben darum kümmern. Und das ist natürlich immer umso schlimmer, je hoheitlicher dieses Dokument ist, weil hier ist ja der Ausweis schlicht gesetzlich vorgeschrieben und bei der SuisseID hat das natürlich auch hoheitliche Elemente, auch wenn das jetzt drei Privatunternehmen sind, weil das ZECO, der Schweizer, ist beim Wirtschaftsministerium oder, Max?
Keine Ahnung, ZECO ist ein Interesse-Ningstherum für Wirtschaftsförderung.
Genau, also so ganz weit weg ist es auch nicht, auch wenn es natürlich keine gesetzliche Pflicht gibt. Im Übrigen, in Deutschland, also beim elektronischen Personalausweis, ist die Signatur auch überhaupt nicht hoheitlich. Das ist sozusagen, was sich der Bürger dazu holt, insofern sind die Unterschiede wiederum gar nicht so groß. Aber ich habe so den Eindruck, dass du den Trend hast, dass man Sicherheitsrisiken auf den Benutzer abwälzt und auf die ganzen Haftungsfragen damit ändert.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall ein Trend und man kann, also was noch gar nicht beleuchtet wurde, ist, dass dieser neue Ausweis ja auch für andere Dinge als für die hoheitliche Ausweisfunktion benutzt werden soll, zum Beispiel für Altersverifikationen im Internet. Und da ergeben sich natürlich interessante Angriffsvektoren, also wenn Cyberkriminelle anfangen, Webseiten die Altersverifikationen über diesen neuen Ausweis anbieten, anzugreifen, dann entstehen da natürlich Möglichkeiten, gezielt Leute mit Ausweisen anzugreifen, die den eben zur Altersverifikation nutzen. Und dann bin ich mal gespannt, ob nicht durch Social Engineering, so von wegen, nein, nicht die PIN, sie müssen die andere PIN eingeben, nicht auch Zugriffe auf ganz andere Bereiche des Ausweises möglich werden.
Das ist eine interessante Kombination aus technischem und sozialem Hack, hmmm.
Na das wird doch passieren. Also ich meine, das sieht man ja auch im Bankenumfeld und so. Genau solche Sachen werden ja passieren.
Ja, also das finde ich nicht unrealistisch. Das ist natürlich eine große Gefahr, weil der hoheitliche Bereich ja normalerweise überhaupt nicht für die Wirtschaft irgendwie zugänglich sein soll. Überhaupt nicht. Eigentlich hätte es nur, wenn man sich gegenüber den Behörden ausweisen soll.
Ja, deswegen gibt es ja da auch eine andere PIN, soweit ich weiß.
Nein, das ist die, die aufgedruckt ist. Sie ist sechsstellig und ist aufgedruckt auf der Plastikkarte.
Da sind wir auch schon bei meiner nächsten Frage, nämlich kann man die Daten, die hoheitlichen Daten, also das Lichtbild und wohlmöglich Fingerabdrücke und Name, Anschrift und so weiter, mittlerweile denn auslesen von diesem neuen EPA? Beim Reisepass ging das ja immer ziemlich einfach mit dieser Basic Access Control, die da drauf war. Bei dem neuen Ausweis ist das ja ein bisschen schwieriger.
Das ist richtig. Musst du mal genauer wissen, was willst du denn auslesen aus dem?
Na, so die Passinhaberdaten, also Name und Geburtsdatum und solche Sachen.
Nein, das kann man nicht selbst auslesen, man kann aber soweit ich weiß, wenn der ausgegeben wird, aufs Meldeamt gehen und sich das zeigen lassen, was auf dem hoheitlichen Bereich drauf ist. Das kann ich auch heute mit dem Reisepass. Das ist nicht für den Bürger gedacht, der hat mit dem hoheitlichen Bereich gar nichts zu tun und kann es auch nicht auslesen.
So, jetzt sind wir bald schon wieder am Ende der Sendung und wie immer bei diesen neuen Technologien entsteht der Eindruck, okay, es gibt also viel daran auszusetzen, man könnte vieles besser machen, aber sie werden ja auf jeden Fall kommen. Oder seht ihr irgendwie eine Chance, dass da noch was verhindert wird? Oder wollt ihr das überhaupt verhindern?
Man muss sehen, was hinter diesem Projekt ist, von den Idealen her steht. Ich glaube, das ist bei der SuisseID schon wieder nicht so sehr anders als beim IPA. Dann geht es um schlichte Wirtschaftsförderung. Würdest du das anders sehen für die Schweiz, Max?
Nein, der Punkt ist einfach, wir sagen da immer ganz gerne bei Diskussionen einfach, so wie wir die Zukunft irgendwie malen können, dass die anderen auch und es sind noch viel zu wenige Applikationen und tatsächliche Use-Cases, die funktionieren, vorhanden, obwohl ja schon bereits 10.000 draußen sind. Und bis Ende Jahr waren es ja glaube ich über 100.000 oder so sein, aber ich sage es mal, 10.000 war die letzte Zahl, die öffentlich war und Applikationen gibt es noch fast keine. Also wie die Zukunft aussieht, das ist ziemlich Kristallkugel für alle Involvierten.
Was ist denn jetzt eure Empfehlung für die deutschen, neuartigen Rundfunk-Empfangsgeräte-Benutzer? Was sollen die jetzt machen?
Also das eine ist, es ist durchaus der Preis zu zahlen. Die knapp 30 Euro müssen auf den Tisch gelegt werden, aber man kann sich ja entscheiden, ob man das für die Signatur vorbereiten will und ob man die elektronische Identitätsfunktion benutzen will. Wir raten jedem, das nicht zu tun, darüber hinaus empfehlen wir die Deaktivierung des Chips.
Gibt es da eine offizielle Stelle?
Das darf man natürlich eigentlich nicht, aber das kann ja mal passieren, wenn man den Chip da zum Beispiel überlegt und er dann nicht mehr funkt. Wir empfehlen das durchaus, weil das ist ja auch eine Sicherheitslücke, die man durchaus mal betrachten muss. Das nehme ich, wenn ich in der U-Bahn sitze, vielleicht der, der neben mir sitzt, nicht wissen soll, dass ich einen funkenden Personalausweis bei mir trage, auch wenn er nicht wissen kann, wer ich bin und wie ich heiße. Aber er kann sehen, neben mir sitzt ein Personalausweis und das wäre mir persönlich auch nicht recht. Man kann ihn also entweder in so eine Metallhülle packen oder aber den Chip deaktivieren, das schadet ja auch nicht. Na, da gibt es die sogenannten RFID-Zapper. Wir haben die ja neulich auch, da hat der WDR neben der Tatsache, dass er den Hack mal ein bisschen gezeigt hat und wie man eigentlich das wirklich macht, also die Demonstration der Sicherheitslücke, hat da auch mal eine, glaube ich, achte oder neunte Klasse eines Gymnasiums besucht und hat so einen RFID-Zapper bauen lassen aus einer Einwegkamera und dafür haben wir auch eine Anleitung im Netz und die haben, die Kids in der Schule haben das ziemlich gut gemacht, erfolgreich, haben den durchgeführt. Wir haben so was ja selbst schon mal gemacht mit so Workshops für Schüler. Wir haben also eine Bauanleitung, wie man aus einer normalen Einwegkamera so einen RFID-Zapper baut. Wir empfehlen aber, die nicht in der Nähe von Menschen mit Herzschrittmachern zu benutzen.
Okay, also lieber vielleicht doch einen ganz alten, heißt es eigentlich APA? A la Loga Personalausweis, das alte Gerät, was wir noch irgendwie wissen.
Der neue heißt jeweils TPA, für teurer Personalausweis.
Okay, also die Sendung ist jetzt gleich vorbei. Wo kann man sich belesen, wenn man noch weiter tiefer und mehr ins Thema einsteigen will?
Also wir haben eine sehr umfängliche Pressemitteilung gemacht, die auch zu empfehlen ist in Bezug auf die weiterführenden Links, weil wir da noch weitere Hinweise geben, haben wir da auch noch mal die ganzen Sachen, die Thorsten und Max in ihrem Vortrag ausgeführt haben, noch mal verlinkt sind, aber auch noch darüber hinausgehenden Links. Wir haben zu der ganzen Frage der Biometrie und der Elektronifizierung von Ausweisdokumenten natürlich schon öfter mal gesprochen und wir empfehlen den Besuch des 27. Chaos Communication Congress. Das ist zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr, wenn wir uns natürlich diesem Thema auch wieder widmen.
Gibt es da schon Karten? Was? Gibt es da schon Karten?
Der Kartenvorverkauf wurde leider wegen, ähm, wegen, ähm, ähm, Aber der Kongress findet statt. Der Kongress findet statt, aber der Vorverkauf hat sich so ein bisschen verzögert, denn wir werden ja diesmal ausschließlich vier Tageskarten im Vorverkauf haben.
Chaosradio 161 über den elektronischen Personalausweis von Swiss ID. Vielen Dank, Thorsten Schröder und Konstant zu kurz, die hier zu Besuch waren. Vielen Dank auch den Anrufern und Mitmachern und mit Wiki-Schreibern und mitchattern. Wir sind jetzt hier gleich raus, geben ab an, es müssen Smart im Night Flight Nummer 123. Da gibt es immer auf Facebook so eine schöne Meldung, was passiert. Ich vermute, also ich vermute nur, der Herr Smart hat mir da heute tatsächlich so eine Art Rap hingeschrieben, aber ich glaube, ich krieg's nicht hin, deswegen versuche ich's. Also den ersten Satz vielleicht. Auf Rap, Dubstep, ob langsam oder schneller, von pervers bis prima, liegt heute auf dem platten Teller. Ich glaube, ich erspreche euch den Rest. Ich kann nur sagen, die Holzfäller kommen vorbei, bleibt die nächsten drei Stunden auch noch dran. Ich bin raus, sage tschüss und natürlich geht auch der letzte Ruf raus. Macht immer schön eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen. Jetzt aber raus jetzt.